this is the long awaited holiday Deep
dive series that everyone has been
looking for on little light when we were
there um unfortunately I was not able to
give those while there so this is what
was to come so let's get into it
together um holiday Deep dive part
one what you want to do first and I want
you to know this is you want to probably
go and recap all of the Bale worship
stuff we talked about and who is the
Rainman that episode um covered all of
that what we're going to be covering
today is a little bit different but that
has some of the foundational um stepping
stones that you need to know to cover
the holidays we also want to look for
our intro to the origins of the Pagan
Sun wheel that information is covered in
the
upcoming episode called the pagan origin
of our culture that is going to be very
interesting I hope you guys will all
tune in so that you can learn the
foundation foundational information and
have the knowledge to identify these
things in our culture because it's a
problem it's everywhere in our culture
and we have to have eyes to see
so after that Spiel like I said let's go
ahead and take a look at what we're
dealing with we have the sun wheel I'll
just do a little tiny overview the sun
wheel has all this stuff on it then it
turned into worship of the Gods so
here's all the gods of Babylon just for
others who did not get that and have not
seen who is the Rainman on bail worship
please go back and watch that still but
here is the list of all of the Gods
names that I am quite aware of and ran
into I'm sure there's more I've learned
little bit by little bit that there is
more out there um so on Earth the Hidden
Truths the seasons and the Pagan wheel
this is important to understand
because the definition of seasons is
each of the four divisions of the Year
spring summer autumn and winter marked
by particular weather patterns and
daylight hours resulting from the
Earth's changing position with regard to
the
sun in paganism this was identified by
the keeping of an engraved image of a
wheel so there's where the sun wheel's
coming from it's according to the
position of the sun and the dying back
of vegetation and cold coming on versus
the warmth and vegetation coming back to
life and in full
Vigor this was also thought to affect
human reproduction so there's their
fertility fertility of the earth
fertility of Offspring as well coming
into play however in the Bible it also
talks about this it um specifically
mentions this kind of
keeping um of the seasons it says there
shall not be found among you anyone that
Marth his son or his daughter to pass
through the fire or that useth
divination or an observer of times
Observer of times is exactly what we're
looking for because when you're keeping
the the feasts I guess and seasons and
holidays you are truly an observer of
time
um and to finish that sentence off or an
enchanter or a witch that is found in
Deuteronomy 18 verse
10 so in wiah I thought it was very
interesting interesting indeed because
they say a Faith with Pagan roots that
evolves around celebration of natural
cycles and Seasons that is what wiah
is does that like shock anyone else and
surprise them to death I didn't know
that it was really interesting to find
out and of course God has something to
say about this as well so it says in
Genesis
1:14 and God said let there be light in
the firmament of the heaven to divide
the day from the night and let them be
for signs and for seasons and for days
and
years all right so he I want to make a
differentiation here this
is what God meant the seasons and the
changing of Night and Day and the Sun
and the Moon to do this is the function
of us being allowed to have different
seasons throughout the
year
however he did not ever appoint us to
worship those
seasons and
times he never ever mentioned to do that
he never said to do so we are not to be
doing that
and just to prove that there's the other
verse Psalm 104: 19 which says he
appointed the moon for Seasons the sun
knoweth his going down so they're
programmed by God they know they're
they're going up and they're going down
daily by his
command and
um so yeah we need to just realize that
this is the way most of the world and
the wicens and everyone is following the
seasons really um and as a Christian
like we saw in those verses it is not
something that if we truly want to
follow God's will he never gave us any
holiday to
celebrate um he gave us the Sabbath and
that was one of the only true
Commandments and days which we're to
keep
holy so here's how it really works on
this picture um the slide has all all of
the different moons a half moon a little
sliver it gives us the scientific names
I guess I'll read it um we'll start on
the top left waxing crescent first
quarter waxing gibbus full moon um and
then it goes back the other way Waxing
gibbus or Waning I'm sorry that's waning
waning gibbus third quarter waning
crescent and New Moon So based off of
that it's also that's what the sun I'm
sorry the Moon is doing now we're going
to look at what the sun is also going to
do that's where this Wiccan um Sun wheel
they call it a season wheel as
well um is going to show us both it's
based off of what they call here an
equinox and a
solstice so you have um the sun
positions which are the stakes the Blue
Stakes and the the black line on there
is where the sun will be changing and
the seasons with
it and so they have holidays which will
fall on those um places but they also as
you can probably imagine with all of
Mythology and I guess as paganism
multiplies there's more Gods there's
more Traditions there's more holidays
and feasts
and um rights to be honest that are
carried out
once you get there and you understand
how this works there is more and more
and more holidays and things added to
this calendar all the time not really
that they change today but they were
when it was created up through
Babylonian times all the way to where we
are now it accumulated all the gods of
all the centuries and an the Ancients
and everything so it is jam-packed and
we're going to look like we're going to
look at those things too we're going to
look at some
very unknown holidays also because you
get a full understanding of why these
holidays exist and they all kind of
come full circle so that you can see
where it's leading where it begins how
it all feeds off of each other so let's
take a look um at what we have this is
what we just saw that Circle that Pagan
Sun wheel became
what I created a timeline here for each
month of things that I was comparing I
wanted to see overlaps I wanted to see
um all kinds of different pagan holidays
that were in the month so I compared the
Church of Satan which you can see in the
legend is going to be blue uh the occult
holidays the um holidays of the dases so
the Vatican church and the Roman
Catholic dictates
and you have Wiccan in
brown Society so that's kind of when you
get into it it's a large chunk of the
people who are keeping these holidays
and I know there's more there's very
specific ones like um probably copics or
kics which are exactly those of the
Egyptian faith that are keeping it all
the way from Biblical Times They are
keeping those gods and celebration and
worship of those gods and everything or
um you know I guess if you really want
to say it that way you could always go
talk
to a very interesting sect of Satanism
which I I don't know I don't have an
example but there are those who are like
claimed to be nais and they they keep
these things too
so let's begin where we need to I know
we're not there with our year right now
but we're going to begin with where we
always do it in
American tradition and that is with
January
1st I want to explain before we do that
just one thing which is very interesting
as I was looking at these holidays and
and uh days in which the Vatican and
dicese
describes our days that we should be
keeping for one holy reason or another
they have what is called days of Feasts
memorials
solemnities and
obligation
days so let's go through this they I
found this definition it's a little
bit um confusing but the rest of it once
you get through it you start
understanding what I'm getting at here
so it says holy days of
Catholicism these
are um ones that unlike feast days of
the rank of
feast like the feast to the Lord they'll
give you the Feast of the Lord the Feast
of the Apostles all these things or
those of the rank of memorials so me
memorializing IGN I'm sorry I can't
speak ignacius lyola and so on from the
Society of Jesus they will do
that um there are solemnities which
replace the celebration of Sundays
outside of
Advent so did you catch that I don't
know if you did but there are Sundays
outside of Easter and Lent and
Advent
which to them they're they're saying
those are very important to them like
those are really
high holidays if you will very special
holidays to them but outside of that
even which they're calling ordinary time
which just fall on every single week are
called The Sundays outside of these
things those they
say um is a word that comes from
postclassical Latin citas meaning a
semity festival or celebration of a day
I hope that this is making some sense
celebration of a day now why would they
all of a
sudden pinpoint a specific day
specifically Sunday as they've told
us that they say Down Below in that
print the white box every Sunday is a
holy day to them
in which it's the Lord's day recognized
as a holy day of
obligation and Catholics are bound to
celebrate in Mass on
Sunday so maybe I'm not saying it very
well but they are obligated meaning
pretty much it is required of you to
participate and go be a part of mass and
these holy rights and rituals every
Sunday not just on Easter Advent but
although it is very strange that most
people go yes I keep you know I keep
going to church I don't usually go to
church but I go to church on Easter and
Christmas and all these things and lend
maybe and where did that idea come from
they're kind of leading us to understand
that it
was actually highlighted by the
Catholics and the dicese to
be very sacred days especially Easter
and Christmas and all that but beyond
that their understanding of how holy a
Sunday is is that every Sunday no matter
what is downright sacred and and
required for a Catholic to
keep isn't that interesting no matter
what faith or background you come from
that should be some
very I don't know a tidbit that should
Peak your
interest so back to New Year's
Day um New Year's Day
is very
interesting it says the earliest
recorded New Year's Day celebration
happened
first 4,000 years ago in
Babylon it took place during the First
new moon following the vernal equinox
now I'm not going to tell you what
vernal equinoxes are and everything I'm
not really
a genus or an expert on any of
that um so I'll just take their word for
that um but it says yes the New Year
actually begins in spring so that should
tell us when you go back and look at
that kind of pale colored wheel that had
a very simple drawing of the Pagan Sun
wheel and the holidays on it that
there's a vernal equinox that is labeled
on there you can go back and look um for
reference
so let me just emphasize that again the
New Year actually begins in Spring and
not winter this was so this was so
because there was an equal amount of
sunlight and darkness heralding the
start of a new year and representing the
rebirth of the natural world okay so
it's kind of like balancing chaos if you
will you might think of the yin and
yang
interesting so this started with a key
to
and a key to um was a
celebration Festival of the Babylonians
to celebrate the new year it deres from
the Sumerian word for barley okay the
festival lasted 11 days and a different
ritual was conducted on each day H all
right
so this might sound interesting to you I
mean my my brain is kind of going off
with alarms
because I don't know if you know this
but there are many days of every holiday
that has different rituals different
rights that
are um carried out on each day of a
holiday especially if you do it the
right Pagan way and do it to a te
so is sounding very overlapping with a
lot of what I've
learned um statues of the gods were
paraded in this Festival throughout the
streets as rights were conducted to
symbolize their victory over the forces
of chaos so there you go I had mentioned
chaos and the balance within of Chaos
and Order which is the Freemason
thing and um so they're directly
correlating to that they said they
believe that through these rights the
world was cleansed and recreated by the
Gods in preparation for the new year and
the return of
spring the principal God celebrated
during this Festival was Marduk please
tell
me it's okay if you're new here but if
you've been watching my stuff so far on
pagan gods and stuff please tell me that
you know who Marduk
is if you do please put a one in the
comments okay that would help me know
that I I am having people retain the
information that you guys are
watching so
Marduk happens to be do we have replies
in in the comments section M okay how
many do we have oh oh right now we just
have four people in okay so that's okay
but I hope you guys are understanding
that Marduk was the Babylonian Sky God
he was also known as Kash and baale okay
they burned children that it it should
all start coming together the dots
should be um
connecting and Marduk was celebrated for
his mythical victory over the evil sea
goddess
Tiamat so during aitu the new King was
crowned or the current Monarch's rule
extended the king practiced a public
ritual of humiliation this is
hilarious during
which he was brought before the statue
of
Marduk he was stripped off of his robes
slapped and dragged by the ears in the
hope of making him
cry if he cried this was seen as a sign
that Marduk was satisfied and
extended that ruler's
rulership now I remember and I forgive
me for not knowing which story that is
but um
I think it was Nebuchadnezzar actually
who had to go through this ritual during
Daniel's
time and um I read an article on that so
maybe you can look it up but is very
strange if you think about a ruler
dressed with royalty and robes and
everything being slapped and having to
cry and then he's seen fit for more days
of r ruling in that country so that's
what would
happen
but um over the centuries the calendar
fell out of sync with the Sun so in 46
BC Julius Caesar solved the
problem he consulted with mathematicians
and astronomers to create a new calendar
based on the sun which resembles the
modern Gregorian calendar
thus Caesar instituted January 1st as
the first day of the year so that's
where the change came from at first it
was during spring that was the first um
of the year and now we have January 1st
as the first day of the year it is
partially in honor of the month's
namesake which is Janice the Roman God
of change and
Beginnings I also hope that you guys
realize that Janice capital one of our
investing and banking
companies is named for the Roman god
Janice um he is called Janice byrons
that's his full name meaning the God who
looks both
ways it explains why Janice Has Two
Faces as a representation of his ability
to look back into the past and forward
into the future this idea was tried to
the concept of transition from one year
to the next from One Vision to the next
and growth into adulthood he was also
worshiped at the beginning of
harvest oh harvest season planting times
marriages births deaths
Etc so to
continue New Year's day was also
sometimes referred to
as dium Duo God of gods if I read that
right Dio sorry
dium Dio God of gods Janice presided
over the creation of religion life and
other gods H so he's being lifted up as
like the King of Kings the god of gods
and
Almighty for this reason he was regarded
as the most important Roman
god his name was the first uttered in
prayers before even that of
Jupiter now we don't have the context
from cultural background um to know
ourselves that that was a common
practice um that Jupiter was thought to
be a great God and so he was supposed to
be usually the first to be spoken of in
prayers but they're mentioning that even
before Jupiter Janis came first
so all right the porter staff and a set
of keys were the symbols representing
Janice because he was the
gatekeeper
H we might see that term again I'm not
sure I might be picking up on it falsely
but I I get a feeling that we're going
to see that term again that's why the
latinized name for Janice which is ianis
is derived
from
IIA bua meaning
door very
interesting gates in Rome named after
Janice were opened during times of war
and closed during times of Peace because
of Rome's constant War Waring the gates
only closed twice from the 7th to the
first century BC these Gates were
called Johnny I don't know if I'm saying
that
right but it's there which represented
ceremonial gateways usually they were
freestanding structures that served as
symbolic entrances and exits these Gates
were also the subject of superstition
the Roman army had a department oh had
to depart by marching through a Janice
you can see it right there um two
examples and pictures a Janice temple in
Burgundy France and Rome's Janis
Geminis which were all like they're
saying portals which they would walk
walk through to get into the
city the most famous Janice in Rome was
Janice Geminis which was actually a
shrine so I didn't know that but that's
actually a shrine to
Janice so Pagan traditions of this time
is that they Romans celebrated the first
by offering sacrifices to Janice in
hopes of gaining good fortune in the new
year they decorated their home homes
with Laurel
branches okay so again if you're new
here there's a whole tradition and
culture within paganism
of holidays and different worship of
certain Gods um having to do with tree
worship different trees are allotted and
so on and uh so now we're being
introduced to a new one Laurel branches
for
Janice all right and they spent the day
praying oh sorry partying that's totally
different partying it's a very small
print so forgive me um it was common for
friends and family to exchange
well-wishes and gift figs and honey
gifts were exchanged because they
believed the beginning of anything was
an omen for the whole So Good Karma
basically if you
give then you'll receive was their idea
so cakes were made of spelt
salt hm which were offered to Janice and
burnt at the
altar I'm not sure what the salt part is
but okay so cakes made of spelt were
offered to Janice and burned at the
altar this was not only done during the
New Year celebration but also on the
first of each month so do you see how do
you see how it starts perpetuating
itself they
at first we just thought it was January
1st that this happened in honor of
Janice then all of a sudden it's
happening at the first of every
month
okay so kissing I've gotten questions
about this for New Year's why we have um
the ball drop and everyone shares a kiss
with their girlfriend or spouse or wh
whomever they're with um kissing at the
moment of transition into the next year
is rooted in pagan sexual practice and
Superstition the Saucy tradition of
starting the new year with a smooch can
be traced back to the winter festival
saturnalia in honor of
Saturn in ancient Rome saturnalia was a
mid December Pagan Festival that honored
Saturn the agricultural God this
celebration included decorating homes
with Greenery like wreaths
Grand feasts uh gift giving and soci oh
sorry socializing with friends and
family does that sound familiar
so I hope again that a lot of this is
all connecting I'm going to say that
over and over again by the way but this
is our
Christmas saturnalia
Christmas so that's not what we're
talking about right now but they're just
pointing you back to where the kissing
actually came from it came from that
celebration
originally and again with the trees the
wreaths and all that um so let's go back
just a minute here last sentence the
winter solstice also meant intoxicated
marry making which we can safely assume
led to well kissing warmth and kisses to
lovers friends and strangers alike to
embrace New
Beginnings so if you're wondering why
people do that now you
know um watch night services were
conducted to watch out for evil spirits
who were believed to roam the Earth
during these
times hence comes the tradition of
staying up to ring in the New
Year aha so there's another question
that most people have on their minds
including myself why do people stay up
that late
well it's to ward off evil
spirits okay eating pork and blackeyed
peas on New Year's
Day I don't know if you're one of those
people who knew that that was even a
tradition I'm not so that was
interesting but they say this originates
from hmage paying hmage to
Janice so his mythological wife Cara
goddess of human organs M
wow
um
was oh now I've lost my place because
that was so shocking to me was honored
during her festival with a dish of fava
beans and pork
bacon okay the Pea and beans symbolize
rebirth and pork or swine was the
preferred sacrificial meat to the
gods huh interesting do does that make
anyone think think hard about why the
Bible if you know this in Leviticus and
most Christians I think mostly know this
that we are called in the Bible to
especially avoid pork or swine
flesh that's probably why because it was
used what they're saying is it wasn't
just used for this God but it was
used um
preferably for as a sacrificial meat for
the gods plural Gods s
so I don't know I'm just showing you how
my brain's working I'm connecting those
dots so hopefully that's helpful to you
too it's the time of the great spring
cleaning so I've heard that my whole
life it's oh my goodness it's time for
spring cleaning where did we get this
tradition well it was a time to purify
the herds and the fields before sewing
before sewing to ensure fertility and
prosperity the farmers roamed the fields
equipped with torches and prepared
pancakes hm okay so pancakes come into
the
mix with the remains of flour from the
reserves of the past
year the shape and color of the pancakes
reminded people of the sun returning
after
winter so unfortunately even our beloved
pancakes which I can say I truly do like
my
pancakes is wrapped up in a ritual to
worship the sun sorry but that is
true so not to say you can't eat
pancakes but just understand where they
come from and
uh I guess don't use them in that
way
so it's the time of oh I already read
that I'm sorry in Britain and the
Commonwealth they are associated with
shove Tuesday commonly known as Pancake
Day okay so they're really ruining this
pancake
thing um when historically perishable
ingredients had to be used up before the
fasting period of Lent so you'd be
really quick about it to get rid of all
of your remaining flour and all the
stuff that you had I guess I don't know
what they threw into it but you would
use the remaining flour and water and
oil and all this stuff before lent so
that you couldn't binge on
it during that
time
so that's New Year's Day for you at
least from the general General
perspective this comes from the
occult definition um from the website
Wicked
Blood and it says about New Year's that
it means to
them
um that it came from the ancient
history of ancient civilizations in
Mesopotamia and
Egypt where the new year was marked by
The Return of the sun and the return of
the Nile's flood
waters these early celebrations were
often linked to religion and the worship
of gods and
goddesses yes so they are they're
exactly
correct as the centuries passed the
celebrations of the New Year evolved and
took on different meanings in different
cultures in ancient Rome the new year
was marked by the Festival of satalia a
week-long celebration honoring the son
of the God
Saturn in medieval Europe the new year
was soon seen as a time of renewal and
spiritual purification and was marked by
rituals and ceremonies to honor the gods
today New Year's Eve is celebrated in
many different ways all over the world
but the underlying theme of renewal and
rebirth remain so as you ring in the New
Year take a moment to reflect on the
rich history and mystical roots of the
Beloved
holiday well they obviously like that
holiday a lot
um but they're confirming that this all
comes from the same ancient pagan
origins that we were speaking
of Druids now usually want when you want
to know something pretty creepy and I
don't know a cult like you're going to
want to consult some Druid sources
because they still exist today and they
do not sugarcoat anything they know
what's going on so so this is from Druid
life um they say so where does all the
seasonal stuff leave a druid plenty of
Druid folks no doubt did stay up to
toast the rolling on of the numbers even
though what we're counting is years from
the supposed birth date of Christ but
it's a good excuse to party and the most
pagans don't need I'm sorry and most
pagans don't need much excuse at all all
it's another opportunity for
excess in case you didn't get enough of
that in during the Christmas bit and
then we all throw out our trees our bags
and bags of postp
party detrus go to landfills and we
shuffle grimly through January the
amount we waste and throw away at this
time of year makes me want to weep but
it's all in the name of good fun and
it's mean to me of me to say that people
shouldn't have a good time
right
so I don't know it's very interesting
for me to hear a druid say that it's
always a good excuse for excess I hear
this all the time from pagans like when
I've looked on forums or done my
research why most of the time one of
their biggest Traditions is always to
drink till you are completely
drunk um across the board all of them
are into that because when you can
always indulge in excess
always I have never seen them not do
that with drugs with alcohol with sex
everything so down at the bottom It also
says the
partying that is daily life helps us
drown out reality so why they do this
because they don't want to be in their
right mind and they don't want to face
reality my guess is they don't want to
face the reality
that they have
regrets they have problems just like
anyone else that they should actually be
facing
and we all need a savior so we need
God's help to get rid of them and
it is heavy it weighs heavy on them all
the stuff that they're
doing each night that goes by when they
drink and don't know what happened maybe
the next morning or they do and it's
just shame and
guilt um that they're packing
down and so it's just really sad it's
really sad that it's all about
forgetting about reality what's really
going on around
you they also add Pile in the easy
calories the booze the brain free
entertainments if you find yourself
thinking at all grab another beer it'll
be fine keep running keep buying keep
consuming whatever you do don't sober up
emotionally because when you do the
mother of all psychological hangovers
will be waiting culturally this is what
we do all the time so they can tell you
without a doubt that this is what
they're doing why they're doing it and
that above all you don't want to be
sober um It also says off to the side
it's all about following your heart I
hope you hear that I hope you're getting
that from this whatever feels good it's
all about
pleasure so it's all about fa following
your heart acting with Integrity living
fully in the moment and I'm not sure
what they mean by acting with
Integrity but living fully in the moment
I can see that it's not about going
along with convention just for the sake
of it acting without thinking or using
chemical props to hide the inner
Darkness embrace the inner Darkness so
now they're even going step further
they're telling you it's not just
about um paying no attention to reality
it's actually embracing the darkness
bringing it on in your life and
embracing it that's really scary isn't
it so they say embrace the inner
Darkness Be At Ease with the doubts and
fears
and go to the party anyway or walk
beneath the stars or both embracing
balance of chaos within it's not what
you do it's how you do
it h so that was that was
truly um interesting to me I don't know
what else to word it was amazing to hear
them say that they know what they're
doing when they're doing this and why
they're promoting other people to do it
as
well and they're very very convincing
Partiers that they make you look like
you don't have fun in your life and like
you should be partying because you're
missing out so
much
okay so January 3rd this is a society of
Jesus um holiday called The Most Holy
Name of Jesus
they say that in
1597 Pope
6us I I think is that I'm not very good
at Roman numerals most people aren't
these days granted an Indulgence to
anyone reverently saying
praised praise be Jesus
Christ
Pope maybe that was Clement I'm not
sure cement
cement the um 7th again you're finding
out how bad I am with Roman numerals
it's a fine pair right there but in 1530
allowed the franciscans to celebrate a
feast day in honor of the holy name and
Pope
Innocent the 13th extended this to The
Universal Church in 1721 what is
universal church do we
know well
actually Catholic Church means Universal
Church Catholic means Universal so
sometimes you need to decode that
because there's it's almost like very
cryptic they're just telling
you it's the Catholic church and most
time they don't want to say it because
they don't want people to understand
that the Roman Catholic church had like
all the control in those days still does
today because whenever we refer
on um programs like TV news media
everywhere when it's written the church
it means Roman Catholic Church you don't
ever
see any other
denomination um mentioned as the church
truly and when we claim that it's our
church that we're talking about as cloy
as we
will it never means actually our
Protestant church it's always the
Catholic Church so just a tidbit there
um so the feast day of the Most Holy
Name of
Jesus um right after Universal Church in
1721 the feast day was celebrated on the
Sunday between January 1st and 6th or
otherwise on January
2nd dropped in 1969 Pope John Paul II re
instituted the Feast of the Holy name of
Jesus to be celebrated on January 3rd so
they changed the name they change the
date a little bit but it's the same
moreover the reverential invocation of
the Holy Name of Jesus was part of
prayer or work and the re recitation of
the Litany of the Holy Name of Jesus
still convey a partial Indulgence for
the reparations of
sin so a Penance Indulgence you
basically buying your way into heaven or
buying possibly one of your relatives or
your friends way into heaven if you say
this litany or Rec you know reciting
this prayer for
them so we all know hopefully I know
there's people who don't unfortunately
but there are many times when we
know um in the Bible it tells you not to
pray repetitive pray
prayers and that is
I'm not sure how exactly that verse goes
word for word but it's pretty
much nonsense to God he does not respect
that in your prayers he doesn't want to
hear repetitive prayers recited over and
over again for different people he wants
you to be personal with him and tell him
very honestly what you need what you
want um he's not of vending machine
but he just needs you to be honest with
him and it it doesn't include repetitive
um mantras or reciting prayers
or memorized
prayers so that's what this had a part
of it as a ritual but it also had let's
see also the holy name society first
organized in sorry 1274 and granted the
status of a co- Fraternity in 1564
continues to promote at the parish and
Dian levels an increased reverence for
the name of Jesus reparation for the sin
of profanity and blasphemy against the
holy name and the personal
sanctification of its
members so they're taking it a whole
step further if you recite this prayer
if you are going to do this and keep the
Holy Name of
Jesus as they are specif if Ying this
would actually clear you of all sins of
profanity and blasphemy against God
against his
name and those of the fraternities so
here we're talking about and I I don't
know if you know this
but this is kind of like secret
societies
having their sins
fully removed
and um eradicated I forget pardoned
pardoned by the Catholic church if they
say this
prayer for specifically profanity and
blasphemy which they do say was a
personal sanctification it actually
Sanctified its
members which no one can
have it just doesn't exist
so
um it was a very erroneous way of doing
things and that is what January 3rd is
so January 6th we have
Epiphany um let's just take one moment
here because this has a lot of overlap
so
Epiphany H Epiphany was known
for being one thing in within wiccanism
and another thing within the Roman
Catholic church or the church when we
say Christianity as well I might clarify
this right now also I try to on most
shows
when we say Christianity this is
actually the Roman catholic's view of
Christians or
Christianity which
[Music]
um there's a problem with that because
again it's not what you and I believe we
we call ourselves Christians but if you
actually talk to a Muslim as well at
least that was in my experience they
asked me if I'm a Christian and I said
yes because I was a follower of Jesus
Christ they automatically assumed that I
was a follower of the Pope when I said
I'm a Christian you don't want that
automatically there was huge amounts of
hate coming my way and that was because
they've been taught that Christians
worship in different ways that
um I guess they hold true to the ancient
terms of Christianity which is your
Roman Catholic you you worship the
church uh the pope is the infallible
representation of Christ here on Earth
and that whatever they do will be
pardoned that they do in Christ's name
even though they've done so many heinous
things and so I can understand their
hatred of me when I said I was a
Christian automatically unfortunately
it's not so
so I don't know there's creative ways
there's different ways maybe that you
want to say that you are a follower of
Christ or you believe in Jesus um you
don't always have to say you're a
Christian because that can get you in
trouble sometimes
and it doesn't mean the same things to
all different denominations or different
cultures so be careful with that that's
exactly what they're talking about here
so
um Epiphany in the wiccan world is known
as la
beana which um would be visually
familiar because she looks like a witch
complete with Raggedy clothes a pointy
hat and a warted a warted nose
she even flies about on a
broomstick she appears annually on the
eve of of epiphany which is the 5th of
January they say the 12th day of
Christmas
now I don't know this is very
interesting they also say the one
Christian mark As the day that the three
wise men greet baby Jesus with gifts
there's the overlap there of what can be
Miss construed as Christian and the
wiccan definition why why this actually
exists why Epiphany exists
um so
labana it goes on to say has her
contemporary name most probably which
comes from epan sorry
epia or epiphania okay epiphania the
Italian for epiphany despite no mention
of her anywhere in the gospel The Story
Goes On to say that labana failed to
give directions to the three wise
men when they came asking about the
location of
Jesus
H but she did offer them food and
shelter which was Jolly decent of
her
so have you heard or of the connection
between pagans putting food out for
Santa at
Christmas I hope so I think most people
have heard of that this is a highly
common tradition in Pagan worship where
you always
offer food and drink at an altar to the
gods I hope that's ringing a bell
also um so all of a sudden you have a
story that's almost promoting this it is
advocating for you to do this and this
exactly supposedly happened even in
Jesus's story
H so it also says after the wise chaps
left Lana decided that she wanted to see
Jesus as
well
H so she gathered some gifts and set off
but she never found him so instead she
left oh sorry she
left leaves his gift
gifts for other other kids oh okay for
other kids the alternate version of this
tale is that she does find Jesus and
gifts and Gifts him up I'm not sure what
that
means whichever way she comes across
quite well in both Tales so she's always
portrayed in a very good light she gives
him gifts if she did find him and
usually you'll find that it's always
hear SA Legend its
mythology there's always little twists
you can find Within These Tales where
she if she didn't find him then she gave
gifts to the children so she's always a
good figure of Good
Will um so that's where we suddenly the
idea of a
witch and to their credit they love it
the story because it does it makes them
look like they're good
people um
that's why it's used but other possible
sources of origin and the most plausible
is via the ancient pre-christian
so I love actually going into the
pre-christian traditions and ancient
Origins because you're really going to
get the true Origins from
that you're not going to learn what the
Catholic
Church uh dictated
as I guess they false reasons why we
have holidays they always have a
different reason
so they call it the Roman Festival of
saturnalia so here we go it points back
to that again a two week Affair that
began just before the winter solstice
and ended in the new year when the
pagans would walk up to the Temple of
Juno stood at top the arks on capitoline
Hill wow so we have Capitol Hill near
the White
House we were just
there this last
week and capitoline Hill sounds very
very
familiar so there's that connection I
don't know you know what's going to what
we're going to find and what's going to
happen there but interesting point that
I had to
make um so they would
go to capitaline Hill to have their
Futures read by an old
woman so here we have fortune telling
and divination probably using astronomy
as
well by an old woman who was
probably a
witch um and here it's not impossible to
imagine that it might be in the Pagan's
interest to offer the old soothsayer
gifts to ensure that they in return were
gift Ed with well-being in the New
Year could this be and quite
honestly is this the true
meaning of New Year's this is the way it
was really kept in ancient
Traditions I think they're telling the
truth I think this is really what did
happen and now we have Epiphany we have
Christmas and all these other things
that are
um Twisted kind of turned upside down on
their head and to mean
that somehow it's a Christian
origin
that bees beneath all of this like it's
just it's somewhere there but I don't
think there really
is so that's just my two
cents um last paragraph there but
irrespective of the
emology Little Italian kids these days
will recognize laana as a magical being
who travels around the skies on a
broomstick and after climbing down a
chimney
fills the
good sorry I have to laugh I'm
sorry fills the good children's
stockings full of sweets and
presents and the bad kids with a lump of
coal
so the idea of Santa
Claus came from an old witch an Old
Witch's
tale whoever tells you
that okay though it's not really coal
that they give to the kids in
Italy it's more like a lump of delicious
black
caramel hang on
access through a
chimney they have it written right here
this is amazing they're going to tell
you stockings filled with gifts or coal
H transcendental unseen
flight on a broomstick I might add does
that sound just a bit familiar or is it
just a coincidence that St Nicholas the
official name for Santa Claus is still
celebrated in Eastern Christian
countries using the old church calendar
with a day of feasting on the 6th of
December AKA The
Epiphany it would seem that outside of
Italy Santa Claus has taken on the role
of leop
labana for the 25th of December but
Santa is well known in Italy so what
does that mean it simply means that
Italian kids get to be the recipient of
gifts
from two festive deity deities oh wow
they even have written there as opposed
to the one most of us get to have so
Santa Claus and La
ofana
H okay then we have St wine ball day
which most of us probably haven't heard
of I know I didn't until I started
looking at the Satanic
holidays I have it listed down there in
the white and highlighted in
yellow it
is um oh sorry we're going to get to
that one it is January 7th above that
one on that list St wine ball day now if
for looking at that on the list given it
says right across if you go right across
to it it is a celebration of blood they
usually have a blood sacrifice that
happens on wine ball
day it is um its usage there is listed
as animal and or human sacrifice and
dismemberment and the age of the victim
must be they don't give an age but
they're supposed to specify what the
victim is supposed to be like it has to
be male if it is
human so that is the satanic holiday
um
ritual now we're going to find out first
of all I'd like to look at this this is
an occult purely
occult um
holiday it says this day is to honor
wein bald originally called Wald who was
a German who became a Roman Catholic
priest
okay
um I'm not shocked about
that around 7:37 bonface visited Rome he
must have been a popular I don't know
politician or maybe the ruler at that
time I'm not great at history and they
don't tell us yet who that
is um but by this time his brother
willibald had returned from his travels
and had become a monk at
Mont
Casino bonface recruited both nephews
for the German mission willibald was
ordained and and based in Ein
I hope I said that
einat bonface received a promise that
winnal would go to
Germany wi Abal arrived in
Thia Thia sorry on the 30th of November
7:40 and was ordained priest
so he was placed in charge of seven
churches including one at
oh man I can't say this
erfort this is German remember so I it's
going to be different but wabal
established established a monastery in
schonfeld but in 742 transferred it to
Heidenheim where the brothers founded a
double Monastery for the training of
priests and a center of
learning wibal here's where it all comes
together
it makes it sound as though he created
the first Monastery I'm not sure that's
true but what we do know is that it's
highlighted in red he became the first
Abbot so that is why he's being
memorialized on that day January the
7th so why I don't know if you've ever
asked yourself this but I'm going to ask
myself this right now and
you why would an oul holiday be
memorializing a Roman Catholic priest
that became the first
Abbot why would they care
about the holy days of basically the
Roman Catholic
Church that is shocking to me that is
it's stumping me
because I don't know if you've ever
thought about that connection is there
actually connection between a cult and
satanic
um things and Roman Catholic
things I hope that I'm not blowing
anyone away I hope I'm not offending but
this is this is just directly from
this has anyone thought of that they're
showing a huge connection this is
incredible so they also said that in art
St wibal is portrayed as an Abbot with a
brick layers
travel do we know what a BRI brick
layer's travel
usually in
Freemasonry
symbolizes I'm not sure what it
symbolizes by the way I said that wrong
but a brick layer's trial is very
important in
Freemasonry so there's another
connection very
interesting he is a patron saint of
construction
workers that is very common usually
Freemasons were Brick Layers
Masons they did they were the first
construction workers that really knew
how to work with bricks and mortar
really well that was kind of their
underground
career while they dwelt in the secret
society and carried out the agenda of
the secret society underneath everything
they did in life so that totally does
not surprise me but I don't know if you
knew
that so that is St winnal day um so far
we are only to January 17
but I want to just cover that right in
the same that's what I meant to do I
created these slides so that you could
see St winnal day and we could also go
down to January 17th as it is
highlighted there as satanic Rebels day
occults have occult people have on their
list of holidays as you'll see here on
this
list they have several dates that are
satanic
Revels where
satanic uh interaction with people
happens where you're supposedly reveling
in in these satanic
Mysteries and this
one on January 17th is said to be sexual
that's what they would do to the
victim it would be oral anal and vaginal
and and the age of the victim would need
to be at least 7 years old to
17 and must be
female okay again that's purely a cult
um on their calendar that's where it was
found on the others although I don't
doubt quite honestly that there is a
connection that when we find it just on
one calendar I believe that most all of
these
are offshoots of each other in a
Brotherhood although they might have a
different Brotherhood name they all are
in different basically different secret
societies where they all adhere to
usually the same
um same ideology but in a little bit of
a different way so they probably keep
the same rituals and rights as
well um but then we get to January 20th
through the 27th again that's the ult
one it is mentioned in the legend up on
the right hand corner but it is on this
satanic holiday list as well I guess
I'll read
that it says this day is for
abduction ceremonial preparation and
holding of sacrificial victim for candle
Mass
H we are going to see what candle mass
is very
soon but they would start abducting
people for this it was for sexual and
blood sacrif ices it
is including oral anal vaginal and Human
Sacrifice completely so at the very end
they would
completely kill the human being it must
be female or child a child of any
age all right so none of this is going
to be um happy uh pleasurable things to
point out but I just want you to be
aware because it all truly
gets gets you a deeper and Fuller
understanding of what these holidays
really are about so thank God we covered
that now we're at the other cult holiday
January 29th which is called St Agnes
Eve I have it on there as well it says
that it is for casting of spells this is
a day that they would do that and so
here's the story behind it Agnes was a
beautiful young Christian
girl again interesting they would say
Christian because Christian the name
Christian came not from our Bibles which
most people think because in the true
Greek and Hebrew and Aramaic that the
Bible was written in the name
Christian from everything I've seen is
not actually the true
translation you don't find that when it
was when you go back into those
translations so the word Christian in my
understanding came again from the church
the Catholic
um the Catholic church that was
dominating
everything so let's read that again it
was Agnes a beautiful young Christian
girl of a good family who lived in Rome
in the early 4th
Century the son of a Roman prefect
wanted to marry her but she refused him
because she was in love with another
Christ okay who was better than he as
she had decided to devote herself to
religious
Purity out of jealousy the young man
denounced Agnes as a Christian and she
was sent to a brothel as punishment so
here they're almost it's strange because
in those days there're they're showing
that it would signify almost that if you
were a Christian in those days you were
going to be punished and tormented and
persecuted however again like I just
said when they say that they are
Christian and the Christ that they mean
is a different Christ than a Protestant
would would be claiming it is the
Catholic definition of being a
Christian and I don't know if you knew
that but they when you really get down
to it is a different Christ in Jesus
that they
are they are worshiping and that they
mean
so she was found out he sent her to a
brothel and there she was spared several
terrible ordeals according to one Legend
all the men who attempted to rape her
were immediately struck blind or
paralyzed in another her virginity was
preserved by thunder and lightning from
heaven now condemned as a witch and pres
sentenced to be burnt to death how
interesting I just have to pause right
there because she said she believed in
Christ here's an interesting
connection and it was truly the Roman
Catholic definition of being a
Christian she's being called a
witch how do you get that where's
how this is either a very very
enlightening term
for what the Catholic Church really
means when you're being a
Christian or it's just a really twisted
turn on top on on its head type of
um I don't know connection that they're
they're specifying here that if you a
Christian you were supposedly said to be
a
witch um hopefully that makes
sense but she was
condemned as a witch and sentenced to
death to be burned the young martyr was
tied to the Stak but the wood would not
burn one of the guards then beheaded her
with his sword Agnes was only 12 or 13
years old when she
died so they've now turned this girl
with all of the different twists and
turns of paganism in the
story into a martyr
and now she is memorialized
every January
29th they say that when her parents
visited her tomb 8 days
later they were met by a chus of angels
including Agnes with a white Lamb by her
side the lamb a symbol of Purity is one
of the symbols associated with St Agnes
this is strange St Agnes is the patron
saint of Chastity girls engaged couples
rape victims and
virgins that's quite a slew of different
things which she presides over one is
Purity the other is rape it's like it
seriously is the chaos in
order together in the yin and yang like
they cannot exist without each other
which is not true but it that's how
strange this is getting
traditionally the night when girls and
unmarried women wish wishing to dream of
their future husbands would perform
certain rituals of divination before
going to bed so this is what you do on
that day that's why they said casting
spells bizarrely these rituals included
transferring pins one by one from a pin
cushion to a sleeve while reciting the
Lord's Prayer
Again The Lord's
Prayer usually is very highly spoken of
and and recited within the Catholic um
denomination while walking backwards
upstairs to bed or fasting all day
another tradition was to eat a portion
of a dumb cake it actually was the name
of it dumb cake a salty confection
prepared with friends in total silence
and reciting a spell before retiring to
bed hoping to dream of a future love in
Scotland girls would meet in a field of
crops at
midnight throw grain onto the soil and
pray I hope you get this this is
starting to sound like a coven meeting
of casting spells um casting drawing
your circle all that stuff that is in
wiccanism the
witchcraft in Rome on her feast day two
white Lambs are offered at the sanctuary
rails in her
church in her church did you get
that it is the Catholic church again
while A Hymn is sung in her honor the
wool from the Lambs is used to weave the
pallum part of the vestments worn by the
ark Bishops in the Latin
church maybe I don't I don't know enough
about that but okay that makes sense the
custom may have been derived from the
folk atmology of her name lamb oh lamb
in Latin is Agnes
okay again you'll see over and over
again there's always a cake there's
always a bread that is
baked in celebration of these Gods as a
ritual as part of the rituals and
traditions so this is what they would do
and um unfortunately I found that you
know in the wiccan
Community there are several this is how
you manifest as well this is a huge
connection to
manifesting that you stay silent and you
have friends over and everything you
share a meal together you have these
specific cakes and breads you
eat but mostly what you do say the only
thing that is really allowed to say be
said I mean is what you want to have
happen what you want to have actually
given to you by the spirit
world and that is because that's how
Satan and his demons work if they they
can't read your mind and they can't
really know what's happening with you
except for what they do know about human
um behavior and what you might be
thinking or feeling and how to trap you
and stuff and they kind of they study
you specifically to know where your
generational sins or where your
particular Temptations are but otherwise
they cannot read your mind so you always
have to speak into the you know air
which he is the prince and power of the
air Satan is what you want from him and
so there's the connection anyway I hope
that makes sense I really hope that that
completely makes sense that it's
manifest manifestation that they are
teaching you which is not a Godly or
Christian
principle so that is St Agnes um Eve
there's a little bit more on this uh lot
more connections I found that while the
dumb supper has come to be more commonly
known today as a ritual used to honor
the dead and our ancestors its Origins
are said to live in lie in a divination
right used to forell one's future spouse
and in some rural regions of the United
States particularly within the
Appalachian Southern and Ozark regions
the use of the term dumb supper is still
mostly used when speaking of the
divinatory
practice they're admitting it's a Divine
divining and where it's being used but I
did not know they're adding to this that
it was used as a ritual to honor the
dead and our ancestors so ancestor
worship a big thing again that in the
Bible Jesus as a Christian we are not
told to worship any other human beings
or ancestors or
anything um first of all they can't hear
us they can't do anything they are
they're dead in the ground and so they
can't get us anything either only God
has the divine power to hear us to
answer our prayers to do anything he is
the only one that is
power otherwise we're all just humans so
those connections are made they also say
that dumb cakes were once part of an
enormous tradition of soothsaying food
stuffs so there was other food items you
apparently made when you were trying to
Divine and tell your fortune or the fure
future Rings hidden in cakes and mashed
potatoes could reveal who was next to be
wed while an apple peel tossed over your
shoulder might very well fall into the
shape of the first initial of your
future spouse these Traditions took
place on the
lional celebratory days of the year when
mystical or seasonal change was nigh
Halloween Christmas Eve and solises for
example so I'm going to take a close
look real
quick that came from
cowoncy and
solstices
okay so we have also from Practical
Magic which um I believe
is the
book by aler
Crowley um it says here St Agnes Eve
January 20th so tonight is oh I'm sorry
this is I remember reading this this is
another Wick in our cult um Satanist
member writing about how she keeps St
Agnes Eve and I put this in here of
course not to subject us to
um witchcraft practices but to
understand that they can vary like they
were saying and she has a very
interesting way of doing this that
connects with today so she says tonight
is St Agnes Agnes's Eve and is a
powerful night for love magic of all
kinds but especially for calling a lover
to
you pause right there for for a minute
we are not acquainted especially as
Christians with uh love magic but it is
a big
deal um you hear this again oh my
goodness I heard this from Megan Fox she
said she used love magic to manifest
Machine Gun
Kelly you hear this from uh celebrities
you always hear it in Shrek Shrek the
movie is a good example you have movies
that are directly showing you love magic
um which is witchcraft and so we need to
be careful with this this is
is not at all Godly and we have so much
of it infiltrating our minds and our
thoughts so that it seems like it's all
just Child's Play it's fun it's not bad
at all that's not the
case so let's
continue um so a powerful night for love
magic of all kinds but especially for
calling a lover to you these sorry there
are several old myths designed to help
you dream of your future spouse's
face according to the Gypsy Magic
website some of these include boiling an
egg removing the yolk and filling the
center with salt and then eating the
whole shell included
wow uh sticking nine pins into a red
onion taking it
back to the bedroom and sleeping with it
under the pillow
a dumb cake ceremony like we already had
it
described she says miraculous
thunderstorms saved her she wants to
give the definition of of how this works
in her history of St Agnes because her
story again varies Mir miraculous
thunderstorm saved her from rape St
Agnes day is January 21st so there is
always discrepancy with those who keep
the solstice they're sometimes on the
ancient calendar
or day versus the day we have have um
come to in our day and age which is
January 29th so there's always certain
occult members that are I don't know
kind of at least between usually January
21st 29th they'll always give a range of
time you keep that holiday whichever one
they're talking about and it's fine but
they say one of the oldest superstitions
associated with this night is that if
she went to bed without looking
behind her and lay on her back with her
hands under her
head that he would appear in Her Dream
kiss her and feast with
her but personally every year I perform
the spell listed in this book the basic
instructions of the spell say that right
before bed you should light a pink
candle Anointed with the love oil of
your choice okay and stare into a hand
mirror while looking into the mirror you
say dear St Agnes sweet and fair does
this sound like a Disney movie to
you mirror mirror on the wall who is the
fairest of them all which I know is not
truly how it
said yeah it's magic mirror on the
wall but this is Snow White This is Love
magic for you
so it's amazing it is amazing how
stooped our culture is and all of this
mythology magic witchcraft all the way
through so the next this takes us to
February 1st or 2nd which is St
Bridget's day or candle Mass so here
you've heard the word candle Mass
probably I think we' heard it twice now
now we're actually going to figure out
what it is um but it's known
also known as St Bridget's
day now what has St bridgid got to do
with candl mass okay well quite a lot
actually they say she began her life as
a pagan goddess and ended up a Christian
Saint so I'm so glad they said this
because this is true this is how these
things they always are coming from a
pagan mythology
origin somehow deemed a
saint in the
Christian holidays
how is that why is that like it's so
wrong but I'm glad that they're
admitting it so let's continue bridgid
was the fire and fertility goddess and
in her Temple at
kildair she was tended by the Vestal
virgins who kept the Eternal fire
going most people don't know anything
about this that's why I'm looking at you
kind of like oh my goodness
you're gonna talk about that I am going
to be talking about that
yes probably more around the I'm going
to be doing my um my lecture I guess on
the Olympics um that will come into play
as well but we also have Vestal virgins
and we're going to cover as much as we
get into it tonight but Vestal virgins
are pretty much
today's actually I won't pop that for
you that'll be a surprise for you they
still exist
today um and they would keep the Eternal
fire
going I hope that you've you've heard of
like
um
Lucifer's
torch and the Eternal Flame which is
kept in his
Temple by beautiful young
women that's what we're talking about
here so they just call it the Eternal
Flame most of the time but
that's what it it signifies here on her
Feast Day her statue was carried into
the sea to be washed which is
purification and then traveled around in
a cart surrounded by
candles they say bridgid was the
daughter of a Chieftain and a slave
woman and was raised in a druid's
household before becoming a consecrated
virgin it's amazing they always seem to
give clues of where
these Tales are coming from the pagan
origins that they are coming
from
and she is patroness of many things
including poetry learning healing
protection blacksmithing
livestock and dairy
production
she racked up 46 Miracles according to
one of her very first
biographers narrowly narrowly trumping
Jesus
himself wow
okay in Time St Bridget herself would
become mure
na I'm sorry in gaale I'm not sure what
that says Mary of the Irish is it any
wonder is it any wonder that now she's
being known as
Mary the mother of Jesus
as venerable as the Blessed Virgin Mary
there you go mother of Christ and second
only to St Patrick in the hierarchy of
Patron
Saints okay this is just
crazy strangely also the story is that
bride okay get to know her as that
because there's a there's going to be a
huge huge connection so bride or
bridgid was taken by the angels to the
Nativity to serve as a handmaiden to
Mary the legends about this bridgid
gradually became associated with st
bridgid who founded the first Convent in
Ireland okay so think back
again
if the Roman Catholic church or their
rights and their holidays and everything
don't
matter why is there connection back to
the this oul holiday it is in Red by the
way this is a purely
occult holiday why do they care why
would they be celebrating why would
there be this thread as for St wibal the
first Abbot okay now her who was the
first what did they say I'm sorry uh the
first
oh who founded the first Convent in
Ireland okay why would that matter why
would we be memorializing
that if there wasn't a connection back
to
the occult Origins within Roman
Catholicism okay it's a good
question
sorry
um I'm just going to leave you with that
so it also goes on to say she founded
the first Convent in Ireland at kildair
of course in the highlands on this day
women dress a corn doll and put her in a
basket which is called the bride's
bed then a wand candle or other phallic
object is laid across
her
okay in time the Roman Catholic Church
is it was want to
do superimposed a Christian Festival on
a pagan
one 40 days after the birth of a male
child which is 80 days if it was a girl
and that's and what what is all that
about they
say Jewish women went through a
purification ceremony in the 6th Century
2nd of February which is 39 days after
Christmas it was declared the Feast of
purification of Mary thereby forging a
link between the two days so now they're
connecting
again connecting the Christian quote
unquote okay I'm gonna have to do that
Christian holiday origin supposedly with
a pagan
one okay the custom was that candles
were brought to church on this day to be
blessed when they were taken home they
act as talismans and protection from
disaster liturgy again liturgy I hope
you understand that is the
um clergymen actually of the Roman
Catholic
Church liturgy loves candles have you
noticed that I mean candles are
everywhere
in cathedrals in Roman Catholic
churches um I know they in other
churches too but usually that's for
another topic another
time um they usually
highly are patterned after the Roman
Catholic Church though so we're just
going to stick with that we're just
going to talk about
that once blessed by a Catholic priest
St bridgid's cross as it became known
symbolized protection particularly from
fire evil spirits and
hunger in the Celtic traditions the
cross represents the
sun okay Sun worship again and people
would and still do weave them on
Bridget's Eve to ask for Bridget's
protection for the home or their Hearth
I I found that in other um references
but I didn't put it there but it's
Hearth as
well fool wise you might want to enjoy
some pancakes okay foodwise I'm sorry I
read that wrong foodwise you might want
to enjoy some pancakes again what was up
with the pancakes
it was Sun worship
again this is probably because shro
Tuesday can fall pretty close to Candle
Mass but it also is good to eat
grain-based Foods so cakes will
do pancakes are considered sun symbols
because of their shape and golden
color again this is amazing because it
came from a different source of what we
had found out about pancakes and uh the
son and so on
earlier
but I don't know if you you probably
don't know but the whole idea of putting
a young
girl in
this you're creating a corn doll that's
supposed to symbolize a little
girl being
basically
penetrated and impregnated by a male
with their phallic organ
that's what they had said there right
here in the 16th century 2nd of
February I'm sorry that was not right
let's go up here second paragraph the
legends about this bridg gradually
became associated with st bridgid who
founded the first Convent in Ireland at
kildair of course in the highlands on
this day women dressed a corn doll and
put her in a basket the bride's bed then
a wand candle or other phallic object is
laid across her why would they use the
word phallic if they didn't mean for
that sexual
intercourse in uendo to be
there so that's really what they're
telling you they know exactly why this
holiday
exists it's for that reason they're
they're wanting to take advantage of
young
girls
so the Vestal virgins let's talk about
this a little bit this is
um it came about in the late 12th
century um Gerald of Wales wrote that 19
nuns took turns in keeping a Perpetual
fire burning at kildair so this is in
honor of St Bridget so this began
again St Bridget she influenced a lot of
things and none of them were really
positive and that this fire was kept
burning since bridgid's
time it has been suggested that five
originally belonged to a temple of
Bridget the goddess so now you have
Bridget and you have Bridget what
they're doing is they're introducing you
to what is usually known as the triple
goddess or the Celtic Trinity where you
have the triple
knot that signifies this you have
bridgid you have
Bridget as they're saying
here um and then you have another one
that comes into it which is usually
Britany and and they're all goddesses of
Mythology so when you do the triple
Celtic knot on you and you think it's a
Christian symbol it is not
unfortunately
[Music]
um so the Roman goddess Vesta and the
Greek goddess Hestia had Perpetual
Flames or fires tended by priestesses
that's where this comes from that's
really at the root of it is the worship
of Vesta and Hestia according to
Gerald or Gerald it was ringed by a
hedge that no man was allowed to
cross lest he be cursed but if bridgid
the saint was many things so too was the
goddess of the same
name
interesting the supposed Celtic goddess
is known as the triple goddess here we
go they're actually explaining it she
was goddess of both the alel power of
fire and the healing power of water now
it's elements of Witchcraft that they're
she's she presides over she's the
goddess of the Alchemy between those
things uh Alchemy of course
is purely a cult it is witchcraft it is
worship of those things and what it can
get you and what it can
make in casting spells usually so
[Music]
um I'll make my point that is kind of
going nuts in my brain in a minute but
Vesta goddess of the Home and hearth is
symbolized by and resides in Her Sacred
fire in Antiquity her fire burned in
Roman homes as well as in the inner
sanctum of her temples in the Roman
forum and other cities throughout the
Empire the ancient Romans believed that
vesta's fire Protected Their World
families and lives and that if the fire
wind out Rome would fall to invading
Barbarian armies to prevent this from
happening an order of Vestal priestesses
was created to keep the Eternal Flame a
light in vesta's
Temple the Vestal order was Rome's only
fulltime get this it's its only
full-time state-funded
priesthood by guarding the flame the
vestals
ensured the pxs
dorium which means the peaceful contract
between the gods and humankind that
would remain
unbroken because Vesta is a virgin
goddess of
fire oh sorry she is a virgin goddess
and fire is a purifying element six
young girls were selected as priestesses
and took a thirdy year wow a 30-year vow
of chaste service to the
goddess 30
years H that's crazy vestals lived a
life of luxury privilege and relative
Independence they were influential in
the political sphere and were venerated
and worshiped by Society at large they
were
um I guess told they were so praised
basically praised is the word I'm
looking for praised by society and after
their 30 years of service they were free
to leave the order as wealthy women who
were still young enough to marry and
perhaps even have children some did
choose to marry as rich well-connected
women they were certainly desirable
wives but many chose to stay with the
order I'll read the last part real quick
before saying what I'm going to a
fallace this is from fandm website
they're going to talk about Vesta this
is really interesting a phus rose from
the Hearth of Vesta in Numa
place and what is phus again a the male
reproductive
organ and okia was the first to see it
she immediately informed the king and
queen and king
tarquinius it doesn't matter that you
don't know these names I don't either
it's just mythology it's just a story
but this is where they get their
traditions and rituals from so this King
upon hearing this was astonished
but tanaquil whose knowledge of
divination was well
known told him it was a blessing that a
birth by the hearth's
phace and a mortal woman would produce
Superior Offspring so here you're having
that hybrid of divinity and the gods
into humankind through impregnation of a
female is meant to be happening
supposedly the king then chose okia to
have intercourse with it for she had
seen it first during which
either during which either Vulcan or the
tutelary deity of the house appeared to
her interesting how Star Trek has
Vulcans in
it and there's the tutelary deity of the
house after disappearing she conceived
and delivered to Tulum or to
tulius when something appears to you
like that it's usually um not godly it's
a demonic presence that
appears especially through sexual
things and
so oh my goodness I just can't okay
today we have we still have the order of
vessel
virgins they live in convents and
they're called
nuns and many of them if you have ever
seen news or you know of documentaries
where they tell their story they're
separated into different classes um
sometimes or they're given different
tasks to do but most of them have to
tend their Hearth the home the convent
as a collective group
and um this whole practice of being the
bride of Christ you might have heard
that by so many priests and the Catholic
church is this practice it's unfortunate
that many of them sign up to be a nun
and devote their lives to Christ but
they are raped by the priests there to
produce
Offspring um for other rituals quite
honestly I will not tell you which ones
yet you'll you'll get to that as we go
through the holidays but that is really
all they're there for and the the men
even though they both take a vow of
Chastity that's why you find the tunnels
between the
convents um and the monasteries and
abies and so on that have buried babies
babies bones and cemeteries full of
babies that are
dead because
um there's another thing I didn't tell
you that ve Vestal virgins and they most
people won't say this because it's so
disgusting if they were found to have
been
you know they could say the priests were
always chased when they were doing their
job right and the Vestal virgins had not
um compromised the nation of Rome's
success dominance and Purity and
honoring the gods as well so that war
would not come upon them you have what
have you harvest would be plentiful all
these things they would go so wrong if
apparently these Vestal virgins were
found
pregnant having not kept that vow and so
um
it does seem that they were
after Human Sacrifice again child
sacrifice quite honestly in this
ritual and um it's just really sad this
is a a hard Truth for a lot of people to
understand but that is why we have um
nuns and convents
today so
we um have to understand a little bit
more apparently about how this all
connects St Bridget's day connects with
uh Druid
Iona and they say right here this is
coming from daily meditations with
Matthew Fox I don't know who he is but
he says St bridgid
druidic uh ecumenicism and the divine
feminine so we're going to learn a lot
through here it says one story tells us
bridgid's mother was a Christian and her
father Druid or spiritual leader in
pre-christian Celtic Society Iona was a
sacred site for druidic pilgrims before
St Columba in the 6th Century the name
he Brides means the islands of bridgid
or
bride thus she stands for a symbol of
continuity in the Celtic World between
one age of wisdom and the next the
pre-christian and Christian
merge with bridgid
the book of linster a 12th century Irish
manuscript says bridgid was a druidas or
leader in that
Community to which the oak tree was very
sacred
Druids worship oak trees basically and
there're they do lots of their rituals
that are very um disgusting and sexual
under oak trees because that's sacred
place and with its roots in the earth
and its reach for the sky
it connected Earth and Heaven so that's
what they the reason they give for uh
doing it in Oak round oak trees and Oak
Groves I guess kildair means Church of
the Oaks so there you have it St Bridget
if it says true she
actually created this entire Convent
with the name Kildare which gives honor
again to Oaks why would you have that if
she wasn't a
druid why would you be worshiping or
giving praise or memorializing again an
oak it just doesn't make sense but it
says kildair means Church The Oaks and
bridgid saw Christ as her Druid so this
is how twisted and disgusting and
ridiculous it gets when she was
supposedly a Christian girl at the
beginning of what we said who was
claiming to be a Christian and devoted
to Christ This is actually the Christ
she meant
Christ was a druid in her estimation and
she was devoted to
him so the last sentence there is the
pre-christian Earth goddess was bridgid
or the great one or shining
one says
Noel the Earth goddess was The Shining
or brightest deep in all things I don't
know what that is supposed to mean truly
but at least are G giving some context
here this is truly what they believe is
that she was a druid one of the most
famous Druids
actually so Groundhog Day who doesn't
think really that a groundhog is pretty
cute and we all think it's amazing and
such a fun kind of silly day we're going
to find out why this matters and it does
come again um straight from candle Mass
which is the occult so you have St
Bridget Day candle mass and Groundhog
Day they all kind of go
together and it says traditionally Irish
people celebrated the 1st of February as
the first day of spring this comes from
the ancient belief that the Celtic
goddess of fertility bridgid this time
with an H in it I hope you go back
through these slides and realize there's
bridgid with there's bridgid without an
H in there and there's bridgid with an h
and there's Bridget and so on you need
to see how this Celtic goddess worship
works with just a slight change of the
spelling
usually and stuff and so they said it
would pass through the land giving
blessings to those who felt her tributes
and who had the power to change the
seasons from frostbitten winter to the
warmth of spring but another character
who was present in the ancient myths of
imul
was the cich I or which
who could allow the winter to last for
longer but there's a
reason that Groundhog Day lands on
February 2nd each year it's inextricably
inextricably linked to St
Bridget's day excuse
me I'm G to get some
water or the ancient Celtic Festival
inul which celebrates the goddess
bridgid since we're going to be talking
about this um probably last inul is
Easter just so that you have that
connection right
now
um with
this rather than the cich Gathering wood
so this witch this woman that they're
talking about that's a witch Gathering
wood for a longer winter came a new
Legend and that is to see a hedgehog on
St Bridget's day that to see a hedgehog
on St Bridges day was a good weather
Omen because if the Hedgehog left the
den it had been sleeping in all
winter it knew that the winter was over
and spring was coming Legend has it that
cich would hope that the 1 of February
would be bright and
sunny which would wake her up early and
allow her to gather enough firewood to
keep warm during The Long Winter which
was still to come
if the day was dark and gloomy the cich
would sleep through the day and be
unable to gather more
firewood meaning that spring was on its
way it's already possible to see where
the Groundhog Day tradition of
predicting six more weeks of of spring
came from but before imul became
Groundhog's
Day it was assimilated into Christianity
with candl mass which celebrates the
purification of the Virgin Mary
so that is truly where it comes from it
was based on an old woman witch that
would come out of her house and if she
gathered wood then they would still have
plenty of days of winter ahead of them
that she had to gather wood for to
symbolize to everyone that it was still
happening if she didn't come out and she
was sleeping through it then spring was
on its
way that was the original
groundhog
uh Clues I guess of of and winter
coming so next we
have let me go back one real quick okay
next we have um another satanic Rebels
on February 2nd as well which is listed
in this white box down below it was
again
sexual and so many times it did have to
be um female of a certain age so they
said it's 7 through 17
um and oral anal and vaginal
sex but as we go further than that we
land
on shove
Tuesday it's known as many things so
that's why we're getting to it just real
quick shove tide three days before Ash
Wednesday and that's why they get tied
together because they are very close
together and connected so shr Tuesday or
Marty gr
okay as it is commonly
known literarily means Fat Tuesday in
French called pancake Tuesday in
England I don't know why the pancakes
are everywhere but they
are and is associated with the Roman
Catholic Church of Lent sorry Church
custom of
Lent the idea behind Migra or Carnival
celebrations is that people
overnight I'm sorry I can't read this
because it's tiny print again
overindulge before giving up something
for Lent which Begins the following day
with Ash Wednesday from Ash Wednesday to
Easter many solemnly mark their
foreheads with ashes in the sign of a
cross fasting or abstaining from certain
foods or physical Pleasures for 40 days
this is done to supposedly imitate Jesus
Christ's 40-day fast in the wilderness
which they claim is from Matthew uh
described in Matthew 4 verse 1 1 and 2
according to the Catholic encyclopedia
however the real aim of Lent is above
all else to prepare men for the
celebration of the death and
resurrection of Christ and better the
better the preparation the more
effective the celebration will be one
can effectively re relive the mystery
only with purified mind and heart
the purpose of Lent is to provide that
purification by weaning men from sin and
selfishness through self-denial and
Prayer by creating in them the desire to
be God's to do God's Will and to make
his kingdom come by making it come first
of all in their
hearts
interesting coming from the anglosaxon
word lentin so there you go it's
Anglo-Saxon by the way it means spring
lent originated in the ancient
Babylonian mystery religion they're
telling you this this is
incredible ancient Babylonian mystery
religion which in the 40 days abstinence
of Lent was directly borrowed from the
worshippers of the Babylonian goddess
among the pagans this Lent seems to have
been an indispensable
preliminary preliminary AR to the great
Annual Festival in commemoration of the
death and resurrection of
tamuz
wow okay
so it is not Christ it's not at all
worshiping Christ it is tamuz it is to
memorialize
tamuz tamuz was the false Messiah of the
Babylonians a satanic counterfeit of
Jesus Christ many of the cultures have a
counterfeit Jesus Christ uh Myra Mitra I
guess is the Roman Catholic one Addis in
other cultures such as the Roman uh
before that
or um Greek perhaps just a lot of them
have it
so the Feast of tamuz was usually
celebrated in June also called the month
of
tamuz this is awesome why
because again I don't say this there but
it's I'm just going to tell you in the
Babylonian calendar which happens to
be the Hebrew
calendar you have the same names of the
month
exactly I hope that that makes some of
you
very very shocked
because it's amazing it truly is in on
the Hebrew calendar the same as the
Babylonian name
tamuz lent was held 40 days before the
feast celebrating by alternate weeping
and rejoicing this is why lent means
spring it took place from Spring to
early
summer those who worshiped the son of
the sun god
then set aside 40 days of weeping for
tamuz they celebrated lent one day for
each year of his incarnation in which
they would deny a worldly pleasure for
his pleasure in the
afterworld now I have a Bible verse for
these
things see Ezekiel 8 it says at the
beginning which is where I'm just going
to tell you God specifically had is
right in there how the women
were Israel by their abominable ways the
women were weeping for tamuz in the
gates of Israel and this angered God
heavily because it's a pagan
practice so it's mentioned specifically
in the
Bible as something you're not supposed
to
do at the end of the morning the morning
such as Crying by the way if you're just
listening to this on the seventh on the
Sunday after the Spring Equinox tamuz
would come back to life and the
agriculture would flourish and the
Animals became fertile the 40-day mour
and Penance had to end on a Sunday after
the first full moon after March 21st to
to coincide with the worship of Easter
the goddess of fertility so they did all
kinds of gymnastics with the date to
make it coincide with Easter so that you
could say that
basically the worship of uh the Weeping
for tamuz and
everything would coincide with Easter
but you could call it a Christian thing
instead of a pagan
thing the Mystic TOA which is the
T on the forehead the initi which the
initial ah sorry the initial of tamuz
name was written in Egyptian
hieroglyphics and in the
old WTIC languages as representing the
cross I I don't know if you know this
either but the cross is actually a pagan
symbol it does mean Tambo and I believe
there's a reason Jesus
was um persecuted
and killed on a cross because he was
overcoming even the worship of tamuz he
was showing that he was above bail
worship or Tam's worship you can go back
and see that connection in the
uh the bail worship one which is called
who is the Rainman please go watch that
if you don't know that connection
but yes the cross
is was meant to show that you were
subjected to you're being put in
subjection to the rules and J judicial
system system of tamuz and so when you
punished on it you were a criminal and
so on and you were going to be justly
punished by the God and feel his wrath
and so because Jesus rose again um he
showed that he was bigger than that he
was he was the almighty God and he could
overcome even that God's punishment and
ways this Mark of tamuz was depicted on
the forehead of Aphrodite which is known
as Samir miss the mother of
tamuz
tulan
from
250 says in all our travels and
movements in all our coming in and going
out in putting on our shoes at the bath
at the table in lighting our candles in
lying down in sitting down whatever
employment occupies us we Mark our
foreheads with the sign of the cross the
Mystic tow was marked in baptism on the
foreheads of those initiated into the M
into the Mysteries he
says now this is very interesting that
he says Mysteries because the only
church I'll broaden that the only
um the only word that uses really the
Mysteries is the Babylonians if you
really want to start way back in time
the Freemasons The Satanist the occult
all the stuff you don't want to be a
part of if you really want to worship
God and so God doesn't speak in
Mysteries or keep secrets from
people and so I've I've also read many
other things and it
says not just the
Mysteries but it was of the initiates of
tamuz that each initiate would get a tea
on their head and that is what Ash
Wednesday is so that incomplete
wholeness is what truly lent shove tide
and Ash Wednesday is
about um there's more to this it says
similarly the Catholic Fat Tuesday
otherwise known as Marty gr is rooted in
the pre-christian Roman celebration of
lupre
Calia
um lalia as I've said you can just get a
clue right down below here is
Valentine's Day so we're not there there
yet don't jump down to there fully but
we're going to go straight back up to
the top again a February holiday
honoring the Roman God of fertility is
what lubric Calia is its Customs
involved feasting drinking and carnal
Behavior today the same can be said of
Marty
gr when Catholics as well as
non-catholics Eat Festival Foods and
party before abstaining for 40 days
during Lent the Spring Equinox was
recognized by various Pagan Cults as a
Festival marking the resurrection of
light triumphing over darkness and the
fresh facundity of the land or fertility
of the
land okay so they're telling you right
away this is not at all again Christian
it's pagans but based on various Pagan
Cults
festivals Good Friday or fish fry Friday
as we usually have known in the Catholic
church honors the fish God Deon
Palm Sunday is traditionally a Christian
quote unquote Christian again that means
it's Catholic
holiday though it has some roots in
paganism much of Christian tradition
arose from the Greek Roman culture I'm
glad they telling the truth there
because if you get anything from ever
being just confused by a lot of things
that the Catholic Church does basically
it's from a Greek and Roman mishmash of
Mythology and
gods truly that's where it's coming
from okay so it Rose from the Greek and
Roman culture in which the palm branch
was a symbol of Triumph and
victory peace and eternal life the Palm
was also a symbol of eternal life in
ancient Egypt where palm tree worship
was
practiced so Palm
Sunday they're telling us is uh directly
related to the Egyptians worship of palm
trees
I hope you know that now
but tree worship why I don't understand
why but
okay so lubric Calia now we jump down to
that in ancient Rome by the way this
picture on the side here of this wolf uh
two human children underneath her um
suckling her breasts the this is lubric
Calia
which is
very very
awkward but here's an interesting thing
to note on Valentine's Day or AKA lubric
Calia it is
actually the colors that I have there
it's from the Church of Satan they
religiously keep lalia day I hope you
know that and they will not miss one of
those days it is also overlapping with
the Society of
Jesus or the
Jesuits okay that's not a good
sign just thought that would be an
important note but it says in ancient
Rome February 15th marked the
traditional Festival of luri Calia which
was an obser observance of fertility and
the coming of spring lubri Calia was a
major Festival on the Roman Calendar and
was commemorated every year on February
15th it was held in honor of the Gods
fonus and lucus the gods of Agriculture
and fertility it also honored the
mythological founders of Rome Romulus
and
Remis again if you're all into
Witchcraft and everything Satanism
jesuitism okay the Church of Satan those
are the people that are
really strict about keeping
this why would everything point back to
the Church of Rome again or the founders
of Rome why why all of this
just ask yourself that Luc Calia was
considered an important holiday of
religious of observance and purification
in the morning the priest of luaus known
as
lupai gathered at lbal
Cave uh
leprechauns that just hit me why do we
have
leprechauns it sounds so much like
lual I'm not saying there's a connection
I have never seen a connection yet with
that but it's interesting nonetheless
anyway back to luriel Cave the place
where Romulus and Remis were said to
have been cared for as babies by a She
Wolf
lucus named lucus The Cave lay at the
foot of palentine Hill the spot at which
the brothers were believed to have
founded Rome
with the sacrificial blood wiped across
their foreheads the Y the youth
partaking in this ceremony would then
run the circumference of the palentine
Hill perhaps about a 5k tracing the
traditional route of the city
boundaries that were traced by Romulus
the day he founded Rome in a
representation of fertility and because
lucus was a god of shepherds two male
goats were sacrificed in the cave
this was followed by the sacrifice of a
dog to represent purification and
because dogs often guard the flocks
blood taken from the sacrificial knife
was then smeared across the
foreheads oh smeared across the
foreheads of the two naked Lu lupri so
there's now they're finally telling you
there were only two lupri that were kind
of Priests of
lucus that were um bless and how to do
the these rituals to honor him and
um what did they say next let's
see the knife was then wiped clean with
a piece of milk soaked wool historians
have suggested this ritual is a reason
why Valentine's Day is associated with
the colors red and
white red represents the blood from the
sacrifice while white represents the
milk on the wound the wool that wipes
the knife clean signifying New Life
feasting followed this ritual and after
stomachs were full the Looper Kai cut
strips from the sacrificed goats called
thongs and dipped them in the
sacrificial blood the lerai then ran
naked naked through the
streets of Rome and whipped any Woman
Within Striking Distance many welcomed
the lashing
how strange is that they welcomed
such whippings basically often revealing
bare skin for the whips to strike them
the Romans believe that the whips beside
it oh would make
children sorry childless women more
fertile while blessing pregnant women
with the gift of an easy
birth the Looper call was situated in
the the foot of the palentine hill and
beside it grew one of the wild fig trees
considered sacred to Romulus and Rome so
now we have the the Fig Tree being
worshiped and sacred to them for another
reason the fig tree with its pendulous
testicle shaped fruit and milky sap so
there you go that's
why why it's important to them was
considered an aphrodesiac and a
fertility booster for men and was often
called the goat fig for its association
with pan
beastiality and male
potency the
lucal was also flanked by a shrine to R
rumina the goddess of breastfeeding a
reminder that a mother's milk of any
species is crucial to their survival of
Rome crucial to the survival of Rome
interesting a Time known by wiccans and
occults for Sex Magic
rituals I'm glad they're being honest
they're just laying everything out there
none of this is ever what I've written
it is quite honestly word for word what
I've usually found pasted together and
given uh usually very tiny I give the
resources and and websites where I got
it from because I don't have room but at
least it's there
you can always zoom up on it so another
custom during lalia was the pairing of
young Roman boys and girls at one point
during the festival the name of young
girls were written on Bits of Paper and
slipped into a jar every young man would
then pull out a girl's name from the jar
the pair would then be coupled together
for the duration of lubric Calia many
stayed together until the following
Year's Festival some even fell in love
and were
married now this is from an occult kind
of blog so they're talking about how
amazing this can be for finding the love
of your
life unfortunately we know
that when you're paired together like
that and you don't know the person a lot
of it could be bad it could be good um
but especially because this is all about
fertility and sex
again this is not a good thing to be
pairing your daughter or girls with men
and boys just to be taken advantage of
basically but this is where we get
Valentine's cards this is why we give
Valentine's cards you're being paired
with someone in this whole idea
of being in love came from
uh this pairing of girls and boys and
having your names written on
paper so then we go to let me make sure
I got that okay now we're in March and
the next big thing that happens is a
cult Holiday by the way there's a lot of
uh different ranges of time in the
calendar which there aren't certain
things and so it does jump like that and
so yeah the next one is in March uh on
March 15th and
17th which is called The Ides or Ides of
March in um they still call it that
sometimes in England or other places of
Europe which gives Credence to this it
says originally The Ides were supposed
to be determined by the full moon
reflecting the lunar origin of the Roman
Calendar in the earliest calendar The
Ides of March would have been the first
full moon of the New
Year The Ides of each month were sacred
to Jupiter so here we go the idea of a
monthly keeping of this Ides similar to
another holiday we we
saw um to Jupiter was also thing Jupiter
is the Romans Supreme
deity the flam Flamin dialis dialis
maybe I don't know Jupiter's high priest
led the Ides
sheep in procession along the Via Sacra
to the arcs where it was sacrificed in
addition to the monthly sacrifice so
they had a monthly sacrifice they say
now they have a um a a second sacrifice
The Ides of March was also the occasion
of the Feast of Anna
Perina the goddess of the
Year whose Festival originally concluded
the ceremonies of a new year the day was
enthusiastically celebrated among the
common people with picnics drinking and
rry one source from late Antiquity also
places the M mamalia on the Ides of
March
this perhaps driving him oh I'm sorry
this observance which has aspects of
scapegoat or ancient Greek pharmacos
ritual involving beating an old man
dressed in animal
[Laughter]
skins why would you ever beat an old
man and why did they do this I guess
we're going to find out and in perhaps
driving him from the city the ritual may
have been a new year Festival
representing the expulsion of the old
year so you're just trying to get him to
run to make the old year
flee in the later Imperial period the I
The Ides began a Holy Week of festivals
celebrating cybel and Addis now they're
being very honest where this actually
comes from it comes from the worship of
the Gods Cel and
Addis being the day that Kaa inro
goddess oh my goodness the Reed enters
Reed meaning like a re
of from the
water when Addis was born and found
among the reads of a Fran
River
frian most of the time we see frian hat
which is a cap kind of like the um Smurf
Smurfs and we have Snow Whites El uh
were they they're not elves they um
dwarfs thank you dwarfs that said they
wore that hat all the time and really
that goes back to the frig and goddess
again over and over again and the
Freemasons who are were also known for
wearing the frian
cap and so it's always giving credence
to the occult the occult the occult
which is so again this is an oul holiday
so I guess I understand
but it's supposedly to the god Addis who
was found in the frine river but we find
that on our our a dollar we find it on
um seals for the state and the
government all the time this Fring hat
so just keep that in mind it's
interesting they're they're kind of
weaving their own web of understanding
if you understand all
this um
so being an old man okay that's not
right celebrating and Addis being the
day Cana
inada that's not where it was he was
discovered oh here we go he was
discovered by Shepherds
or the goddess
cbel who was also known as the Magna
moer this is amazing because every time
they say that it means the great mother
so always think of Mary or mother
Universe you need to make those
connections because these are all the
different names but they're truly
giving throughout history throughout
different cultures that is counterfeit
all the time of a Christian we're not to
worship Mary either it never tells us to
ever worship uh Jesus's mother so they
have these reasons why it's always a
goddess it's always a God they're
they're
worshiping okay he was he was discovered
by her who was also known as Magnum
Mater or the great mother um a week
later on this 22nd of March the solemn
commemoration of Arbor in Trot or the
tree enters we have Arbor Day I hope
that makes
sense the arbor enters it means the tree
enters commemorating the death of Addis
under a pine
tree a college of priests called the
dendr Bor borrow ey or tree
bearers annually cut cut down a tree
hung from it an image of Addis and
carried it to the Temple of the Magna
moer with lamentation or just
celebrating the day was formalized as
part of the official Roman Calendar
under Claudius in 54 ad a 3-day period
of mourning followed culminating with
celebrating the rebirth of Addis on the
25th of March the date of the veneral
Equinox on the Julian calendar
this is also known
as well I'm wrong I actually need to
take two steps back so there's the full
definition of the Ides of March and why
they existed and how they're truly
Pagan but uh when we go to the Pagan I'm
sorry the satanic calendar here at the
very bottom in white
again we jumped over the fact that the
names are so common you have the Ides or
Ides of March with either an e or an i
it doesn't
matter but it also coincides with a few
days before it March 1st on that the
satanic holiday here which is called
Saint
ikad I know it doesn't sound like it
sounds similar but it it does seem
similar which is supposed to be a time
when they do a blood sacrifice of
drinking human blood for strength and
hmage to the
demons and it can be victim of any age
male or
female on March 20th the V the date can
vary somewhat for the Spring Equinox you
have what they call a Sabbath or Sabbat
Festival yes wiccans have sabbaths as
well they have eight of them throughout
the year it is their holidays and it is
Easter that is interesting it is Easter
it is Halloween it is um
many of the occult
holidays and it's a major fertility
Sabbath or Sabbat they say right there
which means that it's for for orgies
this is an orgy
day of course any type of sex goes any
age human female human or animal
so I just give that all to you because I
need to be upfront I need you again to
see the truly
discussing nature of where all of these
holidays come from and really where it
circles around over and over again to
these
things um so that's those other dates
that are needed to be U
mentioned in
the in between there we have the March
29th I read that wrong March 19th which
is St Joseph's
Day oh that's where it comes from St
Joseph's day is also known
quite honestly sometimes as St
einot ikad or whatever however you say
it um which is the blood sacrifice day
so there's the overlap that's kept by
the arch dases and the
Jesuits so all those holidays are packed
together and they overlap with one
another we go to St Patrick's Day which
of course if you
know I didn't give it I guess
but St Patrick who made all the Irish
became oh my
goodness so this is the true definition
here I'm shocked at hearing this it said
that he made all the
Irish using a
shamrock in
400 CE so we are
told we are told that he was taken into
slavery at 16 years of age and sold into
Ireland where he worked as a shepher for
six years but sheep did not ex exist
back
then how how do you get that I don't
know so he would have been a goat herder
oh oh here we go he was during his time
as a slave sheep or goat minder minder
they call it or or herder that he began
to have religious Visions these Visions
reinforced so we are told his Catholic
faith during one of these Visions he
hearded heard voices sorry that told him
where he would find a getaway
ship he escaped went to France where he
became a priest and later on returned to
France to become a
bishop why would you again lift up
somebody
who is Catholic over and over again it's
always a bishop or an bishop or a priest
or
something he also burned many Druid
books um if his confessions are to be
believed 150 Druid books were burned and
on Tara he caused a competition with a
druid book and the Bible to be thrown
into a barrel of water needless to say
the Druid book Druid book sank proving
that the the Bible was a better book but
hang on we are repeatedly told that The
Druids did not have
books they did they do have
books he also prayed for an old Druid to
die and we are told that Arc
Druid named lru was lifted up high in
the air but Patrick knelt in prayer and
the Druid fell and was dashed in pieces
upon a rock so levitation he was
levitating
basically St Patrick is said to have
been have caused the murder of almost
800 Druids the take of shei Beast a she
beast called Koo Rach that he banished
to an island the pilgrimage today to the
retreat center on La durg is a trick for
the followers of this St Patrick
religious religion because it is on the
wrong Island okay I don't know what
they're really talking about fully but
the Pagan cave temple on the island that
the Catholic Church tried to use was not
hospitable to them so they moved their
Purgatory to another island in the same
Lake and achieved some commercial access
for a
while there is a story about Patrick and
two Pagan Celtic princesses and so there
within sight of the Palace of
Kuan Patrick baptized them with the
waters of The Well of
cobach these two priestesses I'm not
going to attempt to say their name
remained for a while on their knees deep
in prayer a rough Stone altar was made
ready and Patrick prepared to say
Mass before the mass began the two girls
came forward saying we wish to
consecrate ourselves as spouses of
Christ Patrick received their vows and
placed over them the veil the first
consecrated virgins in
Ireland then they wished to see the face
of Christ but Patrick replied you cannot
do that until you have tasted the
sacrifice and pass through the door of
death but they said we desire these
things Patrick offered the sacrifice and
gave them the Holy Eucharist then he
closed their eyes and they died
and then this person writes oh come on
why would two Pagan
princesses study as a Drew at a druid
school Under Royal patronage suddenly
want to be spouses or wives of
Christ why are we told that these two
female Druids became nuns who were
automatically Brides of Christ in a
polygamous marriage to the one true
God so this is the actual ult story of
St Patrick um
I know we have if you look deeper into
the usually from a Christian Source
it'll tell you that he was a really
great guy who might have even kept the
Sabbath and he was a slave who tended
sheep and he did escape and so on but
that we are keeping his memory alive and
keeping that celebration
because he was a great
Christian
um not so but at at the same time
whatever religion he was practicing
uh is clearly being lifted up and
memorialized as something on a calendar
because usually it's just because it has
been deemed worthy of such because of
its mythological and God worshipping
qualities
by the Catholic church or the
pope so that's interesting I don't know
that most people know that story um but
that's where you get it from and his
connection with The Druids over and over
again and stuff already tells you
that that he was not in the clear he was
not a true Christian and Christian
meaning when I say that that he was a
true follower of
Christ I
believe um St Joseph's day I had
mentioned that on March
19th we have to read about this because
I didn't know about it much one of the
oldest popular traditions in Sicily is
St Joseph's Day whose celebrations take
place on March 19th sacred and profane
mixed together during this
day because it's surely a moment of deep
devotion and hmage to St Joseph but it's
also a folk lorish Feast rich in
Traditions and joyful
moments
okay although it is also celebrated
during or throughout Italy this day has
a special meaning for Sicilians Sicily
like people from Sicily
according to Legend during the Middle
Ages Sicily was affected by a terrible
drought and famine many people died of
starvation and Sicilians started praying
and begging St Joseph promising him to
celebrate his day with the St Joseph's
table an altar with special Foods
flowers and devotional objects as their
Thanksgiving for his great miracle so if
they would he would do a miracle for
them they would always put up an altar
and worship him on that day
fathers and men who care for children
workers immigrants
prayed for employment real estate most
famously his statue is buried upside
down when selling a
house again it's also for used against
doubt and for a happy
death modern Association
associations with labor rights oh it was
associated with labor rights many
Italian amican societies dedicated to
the Saints began as Mutual benefit of
societal groups of workers who would
pull their resources to take care of
each other's families in case of injury
or death okay but if you've ever
wondered where labor rights come from I
guess we know
now um some of the most famous altars
dedicated to St Joseph are found in
salemi I hope that's not salami or
something Sicily
uh men and women spend five days a week
wow five days a week for a whole month
building these ornate altars the men
build the frames and cover them in Lush
vegetation including seasonal flowers
and citrus fruits the women bake breads
in special shapes all of the gold you
see in the picture below we'll see it
later is bread it's truly breathtaking
St Joseph's altars typically have three
levels
representing either the persons of the
Holy Trinity or the Holy Family
depending on who you ask the large
Breads in the center are dedicated to
the Madonna baby Jesus and St Joseph so
they're bringing in other gods and St
Joseph if
it's I guess mother and Mary and Joseph
like Mary and Joseph uh Jesus's parents
again we weren't told to
worship Joseph the father of Jes
so ancestor worship is really what
they're promoting over and over again
here as Christianity spread we can
easily imagine the local people moving
their worship of the mother goddess into
hiding later on these statues were M
were miraculously rediscovered and
reintroduced into Catholic society as
Madonna so I'm glad that they're
actually saying that this is
not mother Mary it's Madonna it is
a a pagan God they're saying is Mother
Mary from The Cult of Mary so they
actually no it's the cult of Mary the
fact that many of them were found hidden
in trees and underground caves points to
this Pagan their pagan origins as mother
goddess figures they are also often kept
in CPS near sacred Springs and Wells
whether this is intentional or not no
one but the Vatican knows oo so they're
throwing that in the mix only the
Vatican
knows that implies that in all of
history or at least in this
historical understanding but I actually
know that most of history is actually
not accurate the Vatican goes in and he
they change the history that's going to
be reported in your history books what's
taught in schools what is going to be
reported on the news all these things to
be what they want it to be so that it
venerates meaning celebrates and
worships either these quote unquote
Saints or an ancestors or Freemasons or
other occult members or other Bishops
and Priests or a a day that was
worshiped for a different god or
goddess and so I just think it's
incredible that they're mentioning
this um such as the black Madonna or
chartress who was unfortunately restored
and repainted to a white color in 2009
so that's what the Vatican did with all
of these black madonas they changed it
so bread songs and prayers on that day
is what would be known also a Tupa Tupa
skit a Tupa Tupa is where three kids
play the part of Jesus Joseph and Mary
when looking for the
Inn they are turned away by the first
two houses but the third they are
welcomed in inside of this house an
altered to St Joseph has been prepared
the children are serving no sorry served
a taste of every dish that has been
prepared and left out on the altar once
they have sampled each dish the rest of
the guests can enjoy the meal this
ritual reflects a belief common to Many
religious traditions in the
Mediterranean World which is that
Hospitality must be shared with
strangers who may very well be Spirits
gods or angels in
Disguise we are told that that that is
true we should offer to help other human
beings because they may be angels in
Disguise however again this whole ritual
first of all when they were trying to
find an
inn one of them plays the the part of
Jesus Joseph and Mary but when biblical
account actually takes place when you
read your Bible you'll read there trying
to find an in for Jesus to be born
in so this story is already showing that
Jesus was present he wasn't
and just why would you worship St Joseph
you know again I we're not told anywhere
to do
that so here are some pictures um of
what the black Madonna or the white
Madonna that's actually if you go back
far enough you'll find that that Madonna
is the same as Isis um nursing Horus as
I have noted there it says images of the
matress or mother goddess bearing a
child has sometimes been taken for those
of the Virgin when found accidentally
and as they are of wood blackened with
age they are known as virgis noris and
occupy an honored place in Christian
sanctuaries many chur churches of notra
Dame have been built on sites where an
image of the Virgin is said to have been
miraculously found the image probably
being that of a pagan mother so they
know that it's not the Virgin Mary it is
a different Pagan
goddess this is an excerpt from that
book the religion of the ancient Kelts
it says the miraculous qualities of
these figures lends even further
Credence to the idea that they are
incarnations of earlier goddesses many
of them are associated with fertility
and perform Miracles around child birth
lar renetta the black Madonna and
Patronus of C Catalonia is believed to
be in charge of all things involving
sexuality fertility child birth and
marriage an old saying from the
religious or region states that he is
not
well he is not well wed who has not
taken his wife to
monzerat I guess to see that sight and
give praise or worship or sacrifice to
her um many other black virgins are also
linked to those women's Mysteries hence
the massive Cults that sprung up around
their shrines when one takes into
consideration that goddesses such as
Isis emis and Anana were also known to
oversee the same Realms the true
identity of the figure is revealed so
I'm really glad they're they're directly
tying that
connection um but Isis and Artemis and
Anana are also known
as samiramis which is nimrod's wife and
mother he actually married his own
mother and made him made her his wife
and then this was the beginning of bail
worship so we know it's
that okay these are these altars that
they've been talking about I hope you
can see that like they said all the gold
in the the one to the left is um it's
all
bread that have been uh baked very
ornately but you do see tons of symbols
I hope that you've seen one on that uh
particular altar there very
top with IHS on
it IHS is not usually known either for
being Christian it's Isis Horus Seb or
set as there was the Egyptian gods that
were all named that and you could either
be set or Seb
um the second one here is a cup this
whole idea of a
cup ties to a lot of Wiccan ceremonies
where when they're about to impregnate
and rape a girl just as they mentioned
in St Bridget's day they would lay the
girl
down and either put a phallic symbol
over them um upwards where it would
actually go but lay it there or in the
wiccan tradition today when they do the
Hierro U ritual as they did a lot of the
time to make people supposedly
transition to androgyny which you can go
watch all about in my
androgyny episode
um you didn't even have to participate
necessarily in the sexual act you could
seriously just put a knife into water
symbolizing the cup as the you know
vaginal area open and the knife as
the phallic going in that it had been
carried out and that you had been
consecrated to to I guess Satan and and
your vow to become androgynous and
and there were a lot of other ways that
they um there's one other way that I
heard of that you can do that but it's
with a cup so I'm interest interested
sometimes when I see that
cup and how they've even made it the um
Holy Grail you know such as Indiana
Jones and stuff
um there's also what do we have here on
that other
altar there are
I don't know if you noticed the little
eggs but that's
interesting um I guess that's really all
that's hugely important to me in that
picture okay so now we get to Easter
this is our
um last and final stop that we're going
to make at this holiday before we have
basically part two of the holiday Deep
dive that will come next um I spend a
lot of time on Easter just because a lot
of people have questions about
there's a lot more to it that people
don't quite understand and so I hope
this helps um Easter was actually kept
it could be kept all the way through
March 20th through the
23rd
um also known as the 16-year-old bride
of Christ ritual for satanic Rebels so
this is where the bride of Christ again
comes up it was you know as I mentioned
before it is where M of the young girls
would devote their life to Christ by
becoming a nun and that really meant
that they were just going to be um kind
of game for
the priests to use sexually to breed
more babies for
uh sacrifice in other
rituals so becoming the bride of Christ
um it may be a beautiful thing in the
Bible but the Catholic church has
totally changed that meaning into
something else and like I'd mentioned
before many nuns will give their
testimony and in documentaries and
they'll talk about how much abuse they
went through
um conceiving children and being abused
sexually and so on just even um
humiliation techniques and so on that
they went through being a nun and how
the order
of Catholicism and nunery whatever you
want to call it um is not really Godly
at
all so Easter is also known as Ishtar or
o oestra goddess of the
Dawn that tells us a lot and actually I
recently just found something
out reading the Bible and reading about
Lucifer um
Satan all these things he was also known
as I hope I say this right something of
the
Dawn maybe I'll have to add that in
later but he is actually known as being
at dawn so it's kind of like he's the
counterfeit he's a true source of
worshiping what son of the morning son
of the morning and what Venus and Venus
Bing Stu yeah so he is known as that
it's a nod back to
him um but this is what would happen the
saturnalia it comes from saturnalia
again originated at the birth date of
tamuz the bastard son of samiramis the
Widow of nimrod of biblical evil Fame so
they're putting it directly where the
the origin starts after Shem cut Nimrod
this is Shem from the
Bible good guy um
Noah's son
who stayed faithful to him and then as
he saw his nephew it would be his nephew
then or perhaps great
nephew um nimrod become evil and
create bail worship he decided he was
going to kill Nimrod so he did and it it
was right that he did so he was blessed
by God for doing so so he cut Nimrod
into
pieces um and Babylonian Legend insists
that he ascended into the heavens and
became the son God himself so this is
when let me clarify this is Nimrod that
he supposedly ascended and became a god
when that happened the Rays of the sun
implanted the seed into his widow and
Presto she was
pregnant the son of the Sun God was
miraculously conceived as was the
Adoration of the mother and child cult
evident in every culture on Earth today
that is the truth this is truly where
that all comes from and no matter what
it's called in every mythology and every
culture it is truly from Nimrod and smis
and their Sun tamuz that we get the
Trinity and the the mother child
cult uh that happens
everywhere on the winter solstice tamuz
was born they say as were most of the
Traditions surrounding the child Mass
this is in quotations as well so they
actually had a season of child Mass
which is really it's going to be sad
tamuz The Reincarnation of the son
God Nimrod was killed in a hunting
accident when he was gored to death by a
wild boar in his 40th year those who
worshiped the son of the Sun God then
set aside 40
days of weeping for
tamuz they celebrated lent one day for
each year of his his re his incarnation
in which they would deny a worldly
pleasure for his pleasure in the
afterworld like I said Ezekiel 8 it's
directly from the same area says that
this was a ungodly practice of the Pagan
women to weep for tamuz that is what
lent is that's why they did it because
tamuz was their
God the eggs and rabbits that many of us
have always wondered from childhood why
on Earth do they have a connection to
Easter they shouldn't but here is the
supposed connection after many years his
mother Samir Mis died the gods looked
favorably on the mother of God and sent
her back to Earth as a spring fertility
goddess always depicted as an extra
exaggerated exaggeratedly endowed bare
breasted queen of sexual desire
samiramis the Queen of
Heaven was born born again as the
goddess Easter or aarte as she emerged
from a giant
egg that landed in the ephrat river at
sunrise on the sun
day okay on the Sunday after the veral
Equinox to Proclaim her Divine Authority
she changed a bird into a egg laying
rabbit as the cult developed the priest
or sorry Priests of Easter would
impregnate young virgins on the altar of
the goddess of fertility at sunrise on
Easter
Sunday nine months later nine months to
a year later the same Priests of Easter
or Ishtar would sacrifice those
three-month-old babies on the altar at
the front of the sanctuary and dye
Easter eggs in the blood of the
sacrificed infants
this is why personally I have never and
will
never color or Dye an
egg um you are as it was used you would
take an egg and Dy it in the blood of
these children
sacrifice to Ishtar or
Easter why would we want to be um
perpetuating that why would we want to
be a part of it and you also kept it for
the blood that was on it to symbolize
fertility for the next year and remember
your child that you had lost while
worshiping this
goddess none of it's good
so there's that answer the Queen of
Heaven as well was U mentioned in here
Queen of Heaven is mentioned by name in
the Bible as
well I have many many connections with
that uh actually I mentioned it the most
in the androgyny
episode or show so please go back and
watch that if you want more information
on
her
um so let's see here um I'm going to
fill in one of the other disgusting
details is that she supposedly when she
changed that bird into an eggling rabbit
was said to have fallen in love with
that rabbit
and
had sexual intercourse with the animal
so ality is a part of this
also okay so the 40 days of Lent or
weeping for tamuz starts the starts the
Easter fertility season so that's how we
know that it's coming the festivities
culminate on Easter Sunday where the
priests of Easter Slaughter the wild
boar in honor of the boar that killed
tamuz and the entire congregation will
eat the ham of it on Easter
Sunday this comes from a certain book
that I have um listed there Easter
always occurs on the first Sunday after
the Pascal full moon this is the first
full moon that occurs after the vernal
equinox which signifies the beginning of
Spring in the northern hemisphere
according to the Old Farmers
almano so um it is without fail always
on the first first
Sunday after the Pascal full moon do you
know what Pascal
means
um this is the oh my goodness why can't
I think of
it this is when the disciples all
received the Holy Spirit the um
Pentecost thank you so
Pentecost um we're also not told to
worship
Pentecost never has been mentioned to do
so
but they again try to make this a
Christian Holiday by saying you know
that it basically intertwines with
Pentecost and Jesus's resurrection and
all that but it all has to do with
worshiping this God that was
reincarnated
and the sexual fertility
Cults
so Easter always I already read that
sorry
the yezidis or devil wor shippers
of cordan hold a 40-day spring
fast this comes from the book lanard
lards Babylon and Nineveh so he actually
did research on all this and how they
used to do this in Babylon and
Nineveh it was held in Rome to
commemorate the Sorrows of
sess in the early 19th century German
explorer Alexander Von Hult noted the
practice among the pagans in Mexico
being held in Spring his account States
3 days after the vernal equinox began a
solemn fast of 40 days in honor of the
sun Su
n a lent of 40 days was also
commemorated in
Egypt according to English scholar John
landier in his Sabian researches an
Egyptian lent of 40 days was held in
honor of Adonis or
Osiris it doesn't matter what God it
changed from one culture to the next it
was Adonis and Osiris now then it
changed
to
um I guess worship of Easter Ishtar it
just changed names as the time went on
but it's still the same
thing so as we see
here when did this become a Christian
holiday that's the question I'm asking
and it says in 325 ad the Council of NAA
Constantine met to make Easter a
Christian holiday mandating the uniform
observance of the date of Easter so he
just made it mandatory you had no choice
he supposed to represent it's supposed
to represent Jesus rising from the
dead so this is where we truly get it um
the question is asked is Easter pagan
the holiday's Origins and
history from the crosswalk I'm not sure
um if that's a Christian Source or not
now but it says one principle objection
to this Feast is the name Easter is
often said that this name is a thinly
veiled Pagan name drawn from the
Babylonian fertility goddess Ishtar also
known as aarte or asth in other Pagan
cultures encountered by the Israelites
in biblical times the very one that was
always told they were always told to
avoid and not get involved in the sexual
practices of that they looked upon these
rights as they went into the cities of
these Pagan cultures and they were
captivated and and they fell for it they
got involved in these Pagan things and
were they hurt God's heart a lot by
doing so and were LED astray so we know
over and over again throughout the Bible
that we are it's a very God is there's
not just one there's several by the way
because God is trying to warn us of all
the other gods that nothing new is Under
the Sun all these
Gods existed in ancient Biblical times
and now they're coming to the Forefront
under different names in different ways
pretty much they're the same and so
we're just not have anything to do with
them the second part says these names
are certainly similar to the name Easter
however as I noted in other articles the
name Easter is only known from one
single historical Source
written by the venerable Bey in 8th
century English Christian
monk okay that's quite a mouthful BD
briefly identifies the name as referring
to a pagan Goddess that formerly had a
feast at the similar time and that the
old name was used to celebrate the new
Christian Feast so she or he I guess he
sorry he actually is showing us how this
was a pagan Feast that all of a sudden
somehow became Godly quot quote
Christian it was then worshiped it there
was a change there was obviously this
change that was
not right it was
deceptive this is from a Wiccan sight uh
usually telling others um how to worship
ostara on Easter which is another the
goddess name as well and they also give
a backstory on the history it says the
German sorry the goddess ostara and the
origin of the Easter bunny a modern
neopagan tale o star the goddess of dawn
which is a literal trans um translation
apparently in the Saxon who was
responsible for bringing spring spring
each year was feeling guilty about
arriving so late to make matters worse
she arrived to find a pitiful little
bird who Lay Dying his wings Frozen by
the snow lovingly ostara cradled the
Shivering creature and saved his life
Legend has it that she then made him her
pet or in the x-rated version her lover
filling or filled with compassion for
him since he could no longer fly because
of his Frost damaged Wings the goddess
oara turned him into a rabbit a snow
hair and gave him the name lepus or
lepus she also gave him the gift of
being able to run with Aston astonishing
speed so he could easily evade all the
hunters to honor his early form as a
bird she also gave him the ability to
lay eggs in the colors of the rainbow no
less but he was also allowed to lay eggs
on one day out of each
year eventually oara lost her temper
with lepus some
say because he was involved with another
woman and she flung him into the skies
where he would remain for eternity as
the
constellation lepus or the hair hair
forever positioned under the feet of the
constellation
Orion but later remembering all the good
times they had once enjoyed oara
softened a bit and allowed the hair to
return to the earth once each year but
only to give away his eggs to the
children attending ostara festivals that
were held each
spring again there is no historical
documentation or lore that
states this and I really have no idea
where the tale originated from this
woman
says
um this is another thing I looked up and
like I was mentioning Dawn's first light
is the best time that they say from this
occultt source to invoke aara so like I
said Satan is known
for
being something at dawn and so is this
goddess oara AAR Ishtar whatever is
Easter it says as ostara is goddess of
the Dawn we can understand why sunrise
services have always been always been an
important aspect of the spring
Resurrection or Rebirth observances of
other cultures eggs and rabbits are
sacred to her as is the full moon though
there is no historical record of this
since the Ancients saw in its markings
the image of a rabbit or the hair Pagan
Anglo-Saxons made offerings of colored
eggs to her at the vernal equinox
they placed them at graves especially
probably as a charm of rebirth Egyptians
and Greeks were also known to place eggs
at grave sites the goddess of fertility
was also the goddess of grain so
offerings of bread and cakes were also
made to her rabbits are sacred to ostara
especially white ones and she was said
to be able to take the form of a rabbit
herself modern pagans celebrate her
Festival on the vernal equinox we can
see all the overlap uh the cakes and and
breads again the Bible mentions directly
not to offer cakes and those who bake
cakes to the Queen of Heaven and so on
they're mentioning this God directly not
to
worship um and all the ties they're
they're showing directly of going back
to Egyptian and Greek times and the
wiccan connection
here so um just a few other things that
I wanted to directly show about Easter
it says spring is in the air flowers and
bunnies decorate the Home Father helps
the children paint beautiful designs on
eggs dyed in various colors these eggs
which will be later hidden and searched
for are placed into lovely seasonal
baskets the wonderful Aroma of the hot
cross
bun buns that Mother's baking in the
oven
um wafted through the house 40 days of
abstaining from special foods will
finally end the next day the whole
family picks out their Sunday Best to
wear to the next morning's Sunrise
worship service to celebrate the
savior's resurrection and the renewal of
Life everyone looks forward to a
succulent ham with all the
trimmings it will be a thrilling day
after all it is one of the most
important religious days of the
year Easter right
no h this is a description of an ancient
Babylonian family
2,000 years before Christ honoring the
resurrection of their God tamuz who was
brought back from the underworld by his
mother or wife Ishtar after whom the
festival was named as as Ishtar was
actually pronounced Easter in most
semetic dialects or Christian that is
actually the children of Israel were
semites they were known like jph Joseph
was known as a Semite slave setic means
that you are of um Hebrew
uh lineage and you actually have the
lineage of Abraham and all these things
within
you basically you did believe and
worship the true God Jesus
Christ um so that's where that name
comes from it could be said the event
portrayed here in essence
Easter is Easter of course the occasion
could easily have been a Fran family
honoring Addis and cbel or perhaps a
Phoenician family worshiping Adonis and
aarte
I'm really grateful that they made those
connections because it was great that
they were able to delineate where in
different regions of the world you would
actually find it and what it would be
called so they say also fitting the
description well would be a heretic
Israelite family honoring the Canaanite
Bal and
asth so Israelites alone were not known
to be uh those of God they especially if
they fell from worshiping the true God
they would be doing this as well
unfortunately it further says or this
depiction could just as easily represent
any number of other Immortal Pagan
fertility celebrations of death and
Resurrection including the modern Easter
celebration as it has come to us through
the Anglo-Saxon fertility rights of the
Easter uh the goddess ostara or ostara
with an E these are all the same
festivals separated only by time and
culture Easter the name Easter comes to
us from oesta or ostara anglosaxon
goddess of spring for whom a Spring
Festival was held annually as it is from
the Pagan Festival that some of our
Easter custom Customs have come in
Babylonia the goddess of spring was
called Ishtar she was identified with
the planet Venus which
because oh Venus was known as the
goddess of
dawn oh wow
someone said Lucifer is bringer of the
Dawn that's right thank you for that
whoever said that this amazing
connection right there that just I guess
that was the Holy
Spirit okay back to
Venus which because it rises before the
sun or sets after it appears to love the
light which means Venus loves the sun
god in PH Phoenicia she becomes estarte
in Greek oestra related to the Greek
word o or Dawn and in Germany
oara this comes from the Greek word oost
which means East which is the direction
of the Dawn oh we have Sun worship again
we have so much so many
levels of sun
worship as we have seen many names are
interchangeable for the more well-known
Easter pagans typically used many
different names for the same god or
goddess Nimrod the Bible figure who
built the city of Babylon is an example
he was worshiped as Saturn Vulcan Kronos
Bale tamuz Molech and others that is
true but he was also the same God the
fire or sun god universally worshiped in
nearly every ancient culture true
again the goddess Easter was no
different she was one goddess with many
names the goddess of fertility worshiped
in spring when all life was being
renewed so once again um we're just
going to summarize because some people
missed this the first time what's with
the eggs let's talk about the eggs again
isar or samiramis Widow of nimrod mother
of tamuz came to be represented as the
bare breasted bare breasted Pagan
fertility goddess of the East the
original Pagan Festival of Easter was a
sex orgy here they're not mincing words
at all sex orgy that celebrated the
return of Life via the fertility of
ishtar's conception of tamuz worshippers
of the Babylonian religion celebrated
the conception of tamuz on the first
Sunday after the full moon that followed
the Spring
Equinox they celebrated it by baking
cakes to Ishtar getting drunk engaging
in sex orgies sexual orgies and
prostitution in the temple of Ishtar
women were required to celebrate the
conception of tamuz by lying down in the
temple and having sex with whomever
entered
the man was required to leave her money
and babby babies babies were sacrificed
in the honor of these pagan gods and
their blood was consumed by the
worshippers the priest of Ishtar would
sacrifice infants human babies and take
the eggs of Easter or Ishtar as symbols
of fertility and dye them in the blood
of the sacrificed infants the
impregnated women would give birth
around December 25th 9 months later
the same day her son samiramis or
tamuz yeah she had the mother of Samir
Miss tamuz was a baby she had tamuz the
reincarnate son God would be born so he
that was his
birthday this is where the practice of
coloring Easter eggs came from many
babies would be born around December
25th from the sex orgies that began on
the Feast of Ishtar in the spring and
many of these babies would be sacrificed
the following Easter or Ishtar
Feast she taught that the moon was a
goddess that went through a 208 day
cycle and ovulated when full that she
had come down from the Moon in a giant
Moon egg that fell into the Euphrates
River as at sunrise at the time of the
first full moon after the Spring Equinox
on a Sunday this was samiramis Samus
became known as ishar which is
pronounced ishar
referred to as asth or Ashira in
scripture and her Moon egg became known
as an Ishtar egg one of her titles was
the Queen of Heaven and two of her
fertility
symbols were and are the rabbit and the
Egg okay Hot Cross Buns like they
mentioned here's where we have all the
proof it was also common for pagans to
bake cakes to offer to her the Queen of
Heaven on the Friday before the Easter
Festival this is where we gained the
custom of hot grass buns with the cross
symbol indicating the female or the
Babylonian symbol for a
female and a circle with a cross or Crux
beneath it the cross also indicated The
Equinox when the Earth's orbit crossed
the
celestial
equator worshippers were to meditate
upon the sacred mysteries of Baal and
tamuz and to make the sign of the tow a
cross in front of their hearts as they
worshiped what is the group of people
who make the sign of the cross before
their
hearts
Catholics
so that's out of the bag it's the sign
of
tamuz
instead they also ate sacred cakes with
the markings of a tea or a crop on the
top to symbolize the same thing the
children gathered wood and the fathers
kindled the
fire and the women need their dough to
make cakes to the Queen of Heaven and to
pour out drink offerings unto other gods
they may provoke me to anger this is in
the bible Jeremiah
7:18 it's provoking God to anger he
doesn't want this he knows they are
worshiping in
idolatry that goes far into today like
he knew it would go through all all ages
throughout all history and we would be
dealing with it
today the last one the ham well we have
the ham because tamuz was supposed to be
killed by a wild pig at the age of 40
some of his blood fell on the stump of
an evergreen tree and the stump grew
into a full new tree overnight this made
the evergreen tree Sacred by the blood
of tamuz where we get the word Ashira
which means a sacred wooden po host pull
or pillar that stood near the altar in
various Canaanite high places that
symbolized the goddess
Ashira she also proclaimed a 40-day
period of time of Sorrow for each year
prior to the anniversary of the death of
tamuz this was samiramis tamu's Mother
Jeremiah spoke against this practice and
pronounced God's judgment against them
for these practices I give the verses
there if you want to look it up Ezekiel
also speaks against a celebration of the
rights of Ishtar which were taking place
in the temple and the Weeping for tamuz
again I give that verse which refers to
the morning morning such as crying
morning process of the death and
Resurrection symbolism of
Easter sorry Easter Ishtar weeping for
the death of her son tamuz which the
women were obliged to emulate this is
what becomes known as lent in Roman
Catholic tradition Ishtar it's not just
Roman Catholic though it's the Lutheran
and I I knew several friends when I went
to school I went to Public Schools
mainly and so we would have many
denominations we were dealing with just
like anybody else and um it's almost
quite a few Protestant churches that are
keeping lent for some reason and don't
know the true origins of this so sorry I
just thought I'd say that but it's just
it's not Roman Catholic explicitly it's
it's crept into many different
churches ishar also proclaimed that
because tamuz was killed by a pig that a
pig must be eaten on that
Sunday it's Deuteronomy 12:
30-32 it says take heed to thyself that
thou be not snared by following them
after that they be destroyed from before
thee and that thou inquire not after
their gods saying how do these nations
serve their gods
even so will I do
likewise Thou shalt not do so unto the
Lord thy God for every Abomination to
the Lord which he hateth have they done
unto their gods for even their sons and
their daughters they have burnt in the
fire to their gods what thing soever I
command you observe to do it Thou shalt
not add ther too nor diminish from it
right so he's saying that we can't look
to other gods and how other cultures and
other um worship has been done to these
other Idols because that is not good God
is telling us not to look to them to
know how to do anything like that and so
we can't do that and christianize any of
these holidays or things we should not
be keeping
traditions in fact the way I always put
it is the only thing we should be
emulating
is the culture and
traditions that are needed for being a
citizen of of heaven and like I said
Christ never told us to keep any of
these holidays he never told us to
worship the day he rose on or worship
his mother or his uh Father Mark uh 7:9
says and he said unto them full well ye
reject the Commandment of God that ye
may keep your own tradition it says Mark
7:13 making the word of God of none of
through your tradition which ye have
delivered and many such things ye do
yeah so you always make void the word of
God and and his Commandments and all the
good things he has for
us when you start worshiping other gods
basically the traditions and customs of
man we don't need any of that so here is
um our page for supporting us and
donating um we have cash app we are
under dollar sign candid truth official
for venmo it is Mikey Jenny for zel it
is execute brand gmail.com for that
PayPal um donation page that's directly
linked on our our website under donate
um any of these will work we really
appreciate everything thank you so much
and um God bless